uncle joey here [ __ ]
listen let's start this party off right
every time i've taken a lift to the
airport
it's tremendous
whether the ride the driver they got the
purple light in front now a little light
in front to let you know they're in the
house the the drivers are always great i
always have a great conversation i gotta
go on the 405 which is a pain in the ass
what i'm trying to say is when you drive
for the right ride sharing app every
trip can feel like a walk in the park
with lyft you can pick your own hours
and work when you want lyft can make
driving the best job in the world i'm
gonna do you a favor right go to
lyft.com today
and i'm gonna give you a 500 new driver
bonus
that's lyft.com today
joey
lyft.com joey and i'm going to give you
a 500
new driver bonus limited time
terms apply number two bidets are back
there's no reason to walk around with a
stinky [ __ ] [ __ ] and a stinky
[ __ ] [ __ ] all embarrassed and [ __ ]
somebody wants to yes you gotta call a
timeout and go take away [ __ ] that but
days are back and the church of what's
happened now
would like to introduce
the best
portable day out
in the market a portable device that
sprays your butthole clean with water
you understand me hello
tushy.com church and get 10 percent off
all right but days are back go check it
out right now while we're talking [ __ ]
here hellotushy.com
church and they're going to give you 10
off this is the perfect father's day
gift this is the perfect mother's day
gift you even look at your mom cooking
and you're like i wonder what her ass
smells like
anyway
go to hellotushy.com
hit it lee
oh [ __ ]
wheeler walker junior in the house
there you go
there you go [ __ ] the church of
what's happening now wheeler walker
junior lee syed hit the siren [ __ ]
sucker let these people know what time
it is you're slipping already see it
should have been portable
i'm calling he almost [ __ ] died he
almost thought
i'm saying
there you go it's all over uncle joey's
here and he ain't bringing the [ __ ]
cops you had him there waiting for me
[ __ ] anyway
monday or whatever the [ __ ] you gonna
listen to this [ __ ] wednesday march 29th
my main man's here it's a pleasure to
have you on man i'm such a fans i'm so
happy to be here i appreciate it i'll
tell you what i've never i've been on a
lot of podcasts a decent amount i've
never had this much fun this early oh
please this i mean we're in the dive
we're in the first [ __ ] minute and
we're we're in the big time partying oh
yeah we know we have we have to have fun
here and you you like you were like the
nicest person that's ever come in here i
come here and i cough i've puked on
people like next to people before well i
thought you were dying
i took one one long hit he was ready to
call the police
he caught mine as well though this guy
coughed for [ __ ] half an hour oh my
god his face was beat
beat red like those stars how many stars
did you turn i had two of the
transmission fluids well you gotta eat
five more stars to get the part of six
seven more stars oh it's monday night we
ain't [ __ ] around today wheeler came
all the way up from tennessee not that
you know i'm online yeah i want to see
this guy [ __ ] dead yeah no no you
have no idea we we got an ambulance on
call right now hit the buzzer hit the
[ __ ] siren [ __ ] second
we got the ambulance on call here there
you go he's right around the corner help
send help we got noise effects and
everything for you tonight we're going
deep
into the murky waters how was your
weekend lisa i had a good weekend what
did i do this weekend you know what
actually i uh went to santa monica on
friday you walked around i did i
actually went to santa monica i went up
and i i
like an idiot i was a few minutes late i
missed seeing actually willie do the
show but i got to see him after he had
two great shows that was told that was
great the ice house is the ice house is
[ __ ] great i don't know
it's so much fun intimate the drinks are
good oh my god the staff is friendly
nobody busts your balls
what'd you do last weekend brother
me i saw some uh i saw some [ __ ] uh
country music actually some good you
ever heard nikki lane she's really good
you gotta check her out did you watch
her in nashville or here
i was here i got here a few days earlier
she played she just played uh the el rey
and [ __ ] packed house
prettiest girl and uh she uh
she can sing her ass off and the band
was great and uh
sh she might
am i gonna get myself in trouble she
might be singing on my new record but i
don't know if i'm supposed to say
now your new record comes out
june 2nd that new record or another that
one no no we're june 2nd that one comes
out um the new one and uh
the
uh
that's the one that she may or may not
sing on but i forget if i'm allowed to
sing or not
now the first time i saw you was on
rogan
i listened to the jam
i went to a friend's house two weeks ago
to watch a fight
and one of his buddies was there and he
goes have you seen this band
something sad but they put mask on i go
turn it off
like i only want to hear that [ __ ] you
know i'm saying like i don't like that
[ __ ] i like music
you want to play music play [ __ ]
music that's why i'm a fan you you love
all the [ __ ] i love you know like a
skinner sabbath you know christ
that real
real [ __ ] yeah
it's crazy like whenever i get confused
about what what i'm supposed to do
i'll read a book or something i'll write
a little bit and i'll put on scattered
and i'll put on one of the shows they
did like one of the videos from the
shows they did in england
one of the shows in oakland or the black
and white one from asbury park new
jersey
i'll watch all that [ __ ] for hours at
three in the morning like when i don't
need to be doing something and i wake up
in the middle of night all [ __ ]
dazzle
and what i get from it is
they didn't give a [ __ ]
that's why they were that good well
that's the crazy well now that's the
bottom line what's crazy is i when i was
when i was in high school in kentucky it
was like
skinner wasn't cool it was like there
were rednecks and there were like
super rednecks you know like you didn't
want to be like the
like it was almost like
skinner was like
the not cool band and then
you you le then after school you're like
you don't you play it you're like how
the [ __ ] did i miss out on this it's the
best [ __ ] [ __ ] i ever heard
like you was it today you you tweeted
about simple man recently
is today yeah is there a better [ __ ]
song than that no there isn't no there
is it's just perfection you know but i
like that other one too that the
whiskey bottle
brand new car oak tree you're in my way
who comes up with that yeah doesn't it
seem like they just got [ __ ] up and
jammed kind of for a while
whatever they did was working like
whatever they were doing yeah i mean
those first especially to me the first
two records are like there's not a bum
note i mean there's they're both perfect
records like they were musicians when i
watch that video
i love watching musicians tuesday's gone
you like that tuesday's gone i love that
song i love watching musicians
like i love the whole
watching the drummer
you know watch the bass player for a
while i watch a guitar player and then
in my mind i try to figure out how the
[ __ ] are they putting it all together
the brilliance that you have
is the lyrics i [ __ ] love all that
[ __ ] thanks man my biggest
uh
not fear no nothing like that my biggest
envy
is people who could write lyrics
i think that's the toughest [ __ ]
thing i'll tell you what you know i'm
trying to you know when i try to because
people come to me now they want me to
write
songs for other artists and i'll try to
do it
my thing was i wasn't trying to be funny
it was just like i was so [ __ ] p when
i made that record and you i think you
can hear on the record the first one
redneck [ __ ] which can do a plug it's
only 5.99 on itunes how about that
that's [ __ ] cheap
i was i was like i just i don't want to
[ __ ] take like usually you write a
song and the way you would probably
write your jokes you know
although you don't have to but usually
you'll write [ __ ] [ __ ] like you can't
say it on radio exit out so i was like
i'm just gonna make a record where i'm
not gonna [ __ ] x out any of the bad
i'm just gonna if i'm paying for myself
i'm just gonna record it the way i wanna
do it and i
and of course i look back at the band
the studio guys and they're just [ __ ]
on the floor laughing you know because
like you're not supposed to sing [ __ ]
you [ __ ] in the song you don't
how you gonna get on the radio i'm like
i'm not gonna be on the radio anyway i
may as well sing what i want to sing you
know
oh you uh you were saying like you
didn't want to be a redneck like i come
from i'm from boston and
up there like it's there's a real
negative look on like the whole south so
like it's weird it's interesting to hear
even in the south you don't want to be
like seen as well it's weird yeah it's
kind of like it's almost like family
it's like when i'm in
when i was in kentucky i didn't want to
be too much of redneck then i'm when i'm
out here in l.a all of a sudden i'm the
most southern guy you've ever met you
know it's like don't make fun of the
[ __ ] you know
especially out hear you know la's like
very
uh
what's the i mean i want to say i don't
get into politics like liberal but it's
like you know it's like a whole nother
world and they make fun of like the red
states
they look down they look they naturally
look down these [ __ ] mutts
out here naturally
look down on that and it's something
that's
not uh they don't talk about it's
something that's in their dna yeah but
like it's in their dna like if you say
you're from kentucky or
tennessee or
alabama out here
they they giggle
yeah i remember they did that to my
brother my brother went off to school
and he was like
i remember i never heard this joke
before but some guy came up and said man
your phone bills must be so high he's
like why is it because you dock so slow
on the phone it's back when you had to
pay your [ __ ] phone bills by the
minute
and i never even i didn't know he had an
act it's like you know when you're in it
when you're in kentucky you don't to me
my family didn't have an accent then you
lead the state nelson everyone's calling
you a redneck you you get
it hits you really fast you're like oh
[ __ ] i'm the dude i was making fun of
back when i was a kid you know i got it
by the age of like 9 or 10 i got it i
was living in new york city but i go to
florida
isn't it weird sometimes that the
florida's the south you forget i go to
florida
and they had kids that would move in
from
the redneck parts of florida like the
parents got into drug dealing or the
father became a pilot or something
because that's who was doing all the the
[ __ ] mule and yeah with badass
rednecks and [ __ ]
and
i went to his house once or something
they were playing music but my mom
played country music at the bar she had
a couple songs
i can't remember who today i know she
she personally liked johnny cash my mom
yeah i mean she took me to the movies to
see that movie when it came out in 42nd
street we went together
so she personally liked johnny cash so i
always liked it
when i became enthralled with it is with
sports
i saw how the people that i grew up with
acted and i saw how the people in texas
when they watch the football game how
they act what's the difference
they're both fans
but in texas it seemed like that
their heart was really into it
where the people i hung out were doing
it for gambling purposes or
to where the jersey so yeah that's that
was going to say that
where i come from there was there was no
gambling it was like which is a weird
thing when you get to bigger cities it's
all about gambling like
you didn't people would kill themselves
over the games without the [ __ ] they
didn't they didn't need they didn't need
to raise the stakes at all man it's like
kentucky just lost in the tournament
sunday and
i got on the phone with my with my
nephew and he was crying his ass off oh
yeah yeah no no it's real
and i remember like watching
the thing that really pushed me over the
top was watching earl campbell
on monday night football and how those
people would get pom-poms
and when he scored they would all sing
that song
he was denial isn't there all their
[ __ ] pom-pons and i couldn't wait to
go to texas
and i would ask people
you know like uh
adults in jersey i want to go to texas
and they'd say what are you [ __ ]
crazy
they'll kill you down there their
initial
reaction was always ill
you know that's the way they're
programmed it's nothing against them
they just see it that way there's just a
bunch of red next time they don't get it
yeah i feel like it don't you think it's
kind of getting getting worse with this
last election i feel like it's kind of i
don't want to again i don't mean to
steer into politics but i feel like as
of late the the uh
the quote-unquote redneck has been part
of the news even was like you it's
always every news and i don't i'm with
you i don't i ca if i wouldn't ever
watch the news again i'll be happy it's
like it's you dopes who [ __ ] who [ __ ]
voted for him it's your [ __ ] you know
it's like now look what you did
everyone's they're yelling at him you
know that's that's all i see wow
that's the worst [ __ ] thing in the
world that's going on right now it's the
worst it's not even
it's not even funny anymore it's not
even funny it's not even worth putting
your tv on anymore really isn't
whether it's cnn whatever the [ __ ] you
put on it's 15 minutes of this [ __ ]
people [ __ ] scream it's 15 minutes of
this [ __ ] i can't i don't even watch it
no more i live for five o'clock news and
6 30 news i stopped
i stopped world news tonight that's it
no more it's not even
but to go back to your question my
wife's in tennessee yes you're saying
and i've been with my wife since 1999
and when i first met my wife
my wife was trying to act
and you met her out here yeah and she
always came home with a story
and i know from
you know
it's like when you try to talk to a girl
go listen you got a reputation of
sucking dicks
and she'll go what are you talking about
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about i hang out with six guys
and you sucked all six of their dicks
okay what do you think we don't [ __ ]
talk
it's like
they act it's like i had a friend here
that had a mexican chick
living uh not living in a house you know
uh cleaning her house
and every time i go over there
there were people there
they'd act like the woman wasn't even in
the [ __ ] room
yeah that's not cool no it was like a
natural thing for them it's not their
fault
it's not their fault it's it's a natural
thing in you that you look upon them or
you look down on them and i think the
same thing happens with people out here
people on the east coast especially
how they look at people from the south i
always got it i i love this uh
because that was your first thing you
said to me is that you were you said
you're a cuban i'm like
i want to find out where's cuba
it's even more south than [ __ ] mine i
never thought about so that's number one
i'm as southerners can [ __ ] be yeah
number two i appreciate
and i love everything about the culture
and i get the [ __ ] culture you know
i get the culture i get my wife
listen i don't really want to go visit
my wife's family in me
i can't lie to you it's four days of
[ __ ] torture there's only one thing i
go back for that's the least fried
chicken in the walmart
the best walmart in the world i got two
sweaters from walmart seven years ago
american made
they've gone through two laundry
machines they're the best sweaters i got
i buy all my [ __ ] when i go back to
tennessee all that fat man clothes you
gotta buy it in tennessee that's where
they make it good i will say that
uh not really on topic but la is at
least
i actually like new york city for me
i'm not even joking when i say this i i
don't think i've been there 10 times in
my life like
i went there once as a kid and i [ __ ]
flipped when you go from kentucky to new
york city for the first time it's quick
it's just like it's fast brother it
looks
i freaked out like i've never seen
homeless people i've never seen there's
like stereo stores on every [ __ ]
corner i was here with my grandma from
who she's from nashville she was from
nashville
we went there we we had dinner and there
was like a window right here
and some homeless dude just walked up
right to us just dropped [ __ ] dropped
his drawers while we were eating dinner
i think it was probably the first dick i
saw besides mine and i'm sitting there
with my grandma trying to eat a [ __ ]
burger
i was probably 10 or 11. she's like you
know you need to go see a big city
but at least
and even
and i'm saying this is like you know i'm
being honest like the big buildings and
everything [ __ ] flip it freaked me
out man that's not i haven't lived there
in 20 years because i was listening to
was it last week you that jim was it jim
florence yeah jim clark who i know no
from uh stern i mean i don't know him
but i've heard him on stern a lot um
you that's why i love this this show
because i listen to you guys talk about
new york city like specific blocks and
[ __ ] i don't know new york city from my
[ __ ] i listen to the whole two-hour
podcast of you guys talking about little
bars and show you you know
i was like it reminded me i don't know
i gotta go explore new york a little bit
man i haven't spent much time on the
south
is it does it seem like the same country
as like when you go to new york and la
like just the way you like it just
almost seems like we shouldn't be the
same country like not in any negative
way but just you're gonna get yourself
in trouble here um it's crazy i think
i i get i think it's the way
probably for you i mean for me like i
said for me new york city didn't seem
like the same [ __ ] country when i
visited
but probably for some if you if you're
from new york city and you go to
kentucky i assume it's [ __ ] feels
crazy you feel when i was a kid i went
from miami from new york city to miami
and even though miami was a big city
then
not as big as it is now i would get a
little
you know you could go to the store and
do a drive-through store and get milk or
whatever
i travel every week
and i'll tell you what saves me
is when i go to the different states
it lets me know that my hope is still
alive that people still think
the way i do in some cases
you know i do well
in nashville you said you're playing
lexington yeah i'm doing lexington the
last time i did lexington some guy ran
out
and said i'm a christian [ __ ] you fat
boy
some [ __ ] like that
but none of that stuff bothered like
none of that i never looked at it like
that i i got what lee meant to say in a
way which is true
when you go to new york to [ __ ] when
you go from new york to
uh
uh
jackson tennessee which by the way i
gotta tell you something about jackson
tennessee i had some of the best
spaghetti i've ever had in my life
in jackson tennessee see i've had great
pizza in nashville
my mind is open well nashville is
basically a big city yeah my mind is
open where a lot of people's visit you
know you play nashville [ __ ] yeah i
developed as a canal 15 years ago i
couldn't play nashville
well that's a different that's a
difference it was a different nashville
a little bit more christian i bombed i
saw doug stanhope bomb i said this i'll
never come back to nashville you know
because my my my all my all the my mom's
side of my family's from there so i've
been going there since i was a kid
before i moved there
and when i was a kid it was a ghost town
and you might see crystal gale at the
grocery or loretta lynn walking around
and nowadays it's [ __ ] it's turned
into vegas and tyler
it's [ __ ] amazing how many people
live in nashville yeah we had ralphie
man here a couple weeks ago and he was
saying how it's amazing it's like like
he loves it oh yeah but is ralph i gotta
is he cool i don't know him yeah
he's uh he wanted to do some shows with
me um
and i don't
my problem is the agents call so and so
i want to do a show and i just won't get
back to him
but he wanted to do some shows i should
probably get back to him if he's cool
yeah he's cool as [ __ ] you have a good
time with him
but no that's how i look at like i i was
always open-minded to it
i developed as a comic in the state of
texas
i owe the state of texas a lot you name
it because we when i was a kid we lived
in houston for a couple from lubbock to
el paso to victoria
to to to corpus christi to houston to
dallas to addison to austin
austin conroe
pasadena texas beaumont texas
texas was very good to me there's bands
i know there's artists i know who
who you literally no one i
aren't listening would have ever heard
of
who are country musicians who are
millionaires in texas and they don't
leave the state they use tour texas no
that's it it's like its own country
texas is here as a comic you could spend
a month and a half in texas well you
could i'll bet there's plenty of comics
too or just only play texas and make
millions i bet well you know they have a
lot of little rooms that
those agents won't call me you know they
have a lot of little rooms that other
comics have that i'm not aware of
but i developed in texas
that
i never really went to alabama
i went to a couple spots in louisiana i
did well in tupelo
one time maybe 15 years ago as a feature
act
i ate dick in new orleans but new
orleans ain't no [ __ ] comedy
city
and uh where else
clark
tennessee i ate a bag of dicks and a
[ __ ] army base yeah i opened up
i didn't have the money to pay the band
so i opened up for dave alan cove in
chattanooga just me with an acoustic
guitar and [ __ ]
yeah i ate ate a bag of dicks there i
mean it was like
there's two it's two it's almost like
you it's like it's almost there was no
not enough noise now chattanooga is a
college town
no i don't think so
i don't know
yeah
what's in chattanooga university of
tennessee no that's knoxville knoxville
you're right
the chattanooga was has the trains but
chattanooga actually used to be almost
bigger than nashville because had the
chattanooga choo choo it used to be the
place to be now knoxville was good to me
too they had a good record store in
knoxville haven't been there again in 15
years
this is
well i'll say even for me as a country
musician you know you know if it makes
you feel better the more almost deep
south i go the less the audiences show
up just because
you know like i can sell out a show in
l.a
because you only gotta sell to one
percent of the [ __ ] city once you get
down to like lower south and small towns
like to sell out the gig everyone in
town's got to [ __ ] show up it's just
tougher it's like they're not on the
internet they're on twitter they don't
give a [ __ ] about that [ __ ] so
even with country music it's tough now
when you go to nashville and play a lot
of people show up
yeah decent well we're doing
can i do my second plug
we're doing three
dates to three record release shows june
2nd in nashville
at the exit end june 6th new york city
bowery ballroom never been there is it
cool i've never been there june 8th l.a
troubadour you guys want to come yeah
june 8th
that what night is that thursday i have
no [ __ ] yeah something it looks like
i gotta stay in bray i got i got bray
well if you got some time we got an
opening bed you can do it do a little
some joking yeah no no no no doing some
jokes between them here is your name
i'll go watch it
absolutely i'll go watch it the trouble
though because dantanis is right next
door
so trust me it's easy
it was pretty good for country music i
heard in the old days
well isn't that where the eagles started
and wants that yeah a lot of that kind
of exactly which is that country i don't
know but yeah no yeah i think so easy
listening is what they called it yeah i
hate that term but yeah i guess it was
you know you can't deny that eagles have
good songs but um
uh yeah that's where all that [ __ ]
started
man i love flying burrito brothers you
ever listened to that yeah a while back
graham parsons and all that [ __ ] that
was all uh troubadour i think
we did that we played it on our last
tour i remember because i love guns and
roses and guys and rosie just played
there for like to warm up for the show
he's explained to me how like axel would
come back for his like his like
uh
what's it called his pep talk costume
changes and
i don't know if i'm supposed to say it
but like he would take his like oxygen
puffs and [ __ ] back there i don't know
yeah when you you know that guy moves
around a lot
the troubadour was probably that warm-up
gig that's not a big spot is it
no it was really small it was
cool to be there like a week or so after
uh axel and the gang and all them were
there now how long have you been playing
music
i mean i've been playing music my whole
life but um and you composed all these
songs
yeah yeah uh
there were there were 11 songs on the
redneck [ __ ] the first record the one
you like which i again i appreciate
um
i wrote all those myself
there's 11 on the new one that's coming
out june 2nd and i wrote all i wrote all
those except for three i co-wrote with
friends so i don't think i don't sing
anything i i'll play like a whalen song
or whaling cover live
i'll do a couple covers live but
i don't record anything that i don't
write when you do the whaling songs you
throw a little zinger in there just well
i do i purposely do one the people don't
know that well it's called outlaw [ __ ]
it's one of my favorite songs ever um
and waylon um actually my
my buddy who did my records actually did
this
did that it was actually
they finished it after he passed aways
um
and shooter jennings redid it with my
dave cobb
an amazing producer who did my records
and so the guys who
because i played the song because
the guys i knew in the in the in my band
had
played on the record
it's like i'm gonna play [ __ ] whaling
with the guys who played with weyland
and i found out later that they [ __ ]
this dude's even [ __ ] play on the
record
now do you work texas a lot still
no a little bit i'm gonna do i'll bet
i'll do more this year
but when you go down there where do you
play
well we this last you know it's weird
doing music because you don't when the
first album comes out you don't know
how big do you play
hundred two hundred a thousand five we
played like probably 500 ish rooms you
know what [ __ ] sucks and uh we played
a lot of these like i don't know if
there's an equivalent in comedy but we
played a lot of these [ __ ] like um
they have like a house of blues which i
[ __ ] it's all you know it's like
the almost like the [ __ ] uh chili's
of music clubs
although i do like chili's um
and then they're like the main room in
the set we play a lot of sec like the
second rooms where you're like we do a
sound check and they're like
hey man you got a uh mic for a kick drum
i'm like i don't
know it's like oh [ __ ] they're using it
upstairs like it was like leftovers
almost i think they use it mainly for
like [ __ ] parties what do they call
that room there's a room for that little
i don't know a house of blues but that's
what i call my
i called my i called my agent i go don't
play don't book me any more [ __ ]
shows where they're selling blues
brothers dvds that's my new rule
if they're selling the blues brothers
dvd or they're selling or if they're
selling top hats with a black [ __ ]
suit and tie i don't want to play there
nothing against the blues brothers but
like
it's not
the best [ __ ] sound in the world
no well they all have those uh when i
was in louisiana shooting one time
i called my age and i go yeah i want to
do louisiana is there anything in new
orleans yeah there's a house of blues
i'll get you a number for the room
it was it was only 714 people
that's it
i was like i have to do 22 shows
i might as well do it at this little and
they wanted a ton of loot so i had to do
a little theater right in the heart of
yeah though we played new orleans was
the craziest gig we got in right before
the [ __ ] show cause it was like
something there was some accident on the
highway and we got him right
it would actually turn out to be a great
gig but there weren't that many people
there it was like
it's like you're in
[ __ ] jazz you know you can see any
music you want it's hard to like
grab a
grab an audience when there's like
[ __ ] gray's jazz now i feel like you
could [ __ ] grab any audience
like they'll be at a ball looking at the
[ __ ] college game
and they'll go what the [ __ ] did he just
say
yeah well that's the thing is you gotta
you got you gotta get people to know
about but the problem is and where i had
a blast last time was with like
the scene you guys know which i didn't
really know about which is
i'm gonna
so i put out this dirty record i'm like
i'm not censoring it and then i was like
my p my [ __ ] people which is just one
[ __ ] doofus it's like
there's no radio there's no nothing when
i come out here i do rogan i do
you know
like fit simmons i do all these podcasts
and [ __ ] it's like
that's bigger than any of my friends
who'd ever done [ __ ] the tonight show
or any of that [ __ ] there's this
underground thing you do youtube
channels and [ __ ] like that it's like
the world is [ __ ] opened up
to um
and i'll tell you right now that i
actually just sent him shot a message to
rogan before i came over here to tell
him that was coming here but
he's like doing like 50 nights on the
tonight show yeah no it's like the the
tonight you wrote joe rogan's
show is like doing an hbo special
for a comic if you go on there
and [ __ ] kill it you know today i was
really upset i've been upset all day so
i came here to see you tonight yeah i
cheer all that i got home like at 4 30.
i'm trying to pitch a [ __ ] tv show
you know and it's like
i gotta tell you in the middle of
pitching it
i'm like do i even normally [ __ ] do
this
do i really want to even do this a
little more you know why was it your did
it start with you
yeah it's it's a it's a show with
pitching it's a great show it's great
written but this time as i'm sitting
there going
why do i want a tv show that's [ __ ]
work
isn't it weird how that happens that's
work if i want to do anything i might as
well come in here every night at 8
o'clock
and do an eight o'clock [ __ ] tonight
show here get a band to get a house band
get a [ __ ] studio that's what i want
to do is get on here from eight [ __ ]
watch it i think uh i don't think we had
this on the air but i saw you when i was
out here doing press and i did i told
you i did fitzsimmons podcast and he
invited me out to do uh
to watch go to a show at the improv like
i'll go and all these [ __ ] uh
kind of cool comedians galifianakis
sarah silva all came on stage and you
came on stage i'd never heard of you
before
and
you told me just now that you were felt
a little out of place which you look i
was like i don't know if this guy fits
in with the bill
and then five minutes in i'm like my new
favorite comment right here is the
funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever heard
because it was like mixed in with all
that kind of weird kind of stuff was
like all right this is
this is what it's almost like pure
country music it's like this is what i
like [ __ ] jokes no i had to go out
and heavy that night they weren't taking
do you remember the gig oh please i know
the gig because that guy from knackers
called me
and said what the [ __ ] was that tonight
you know brody called me and said zach
called me he said that
that was the craziest set he ever saw in
his life i had to go take it from him i
don't have time oh dude you you came on
and you [ __ ] [ __ ] off the
floor yeah i mean it was it was
it was it was like watching hendrix i
mean the hollywood improv is very pc
oh yeah they try to pc it on you for
certain shows in that show they try to
be haha and he he
and you know what i'm not going down a
hill for you to be hot honey he again i
go back but you had that you had a
[ __ ] attitude then yeah in a great
way like kind of like [ __ ] all you
[ __ ] for for even showing up or like
that's that's kind of what i love well
again we go back to skinned
76 at the oakland coliseum look at them
on stage look at the singer
you can't give a [ __ ] yeah he didn't
jump around he didn't show you his
tattoos his hair wasn't combed
he probably smelled like a billy goat
they were drinking bud wise out of a can
at the end watch he just ends the songs
like this
there's no jumping up and down and
acting like you gotta [ __ ] nothing
yes the art of not giving a [ __ ] i think
with my first record i was like you
eliminated
they're like can we they ask me for a
bleeped version
i go i own the [ __ ] record no there's
no bleep version because i go i don't
care if it sells and then it started
taking off and i'm like
then you got to watch yourself because
then i started you start to care you're
like [ __ ] should i have should i have a
bleep version
then you're going to be like
then you got to be like [ __ ] low that
little your original thought
is the right [ __ ] instinct you know
you you it's when we double check
ourselves that we [ __ ] up it's when you
listen to people which is hard that's
hard too
hard these days because everyone has
access to you you know no well
the problem that you have especially in
our situation
this is the podcast that we started from
a ground rule situation
and we've gone through all the hurdles
ourselves like you did you follow these
hurdles yeah and then it gets to a point
that you have this growth
and now people are coming in and [ __ ]
with your growth
oh dude yeah they [ __ ] with your growth
and
unless you tell them knock it off this
ain't gonna work unless you do it my way
i've been doing this since day one
you're a johnny come lately type of
[ __ ] and now you want to give
orders
it doesn't work oh nashville's trying
like not even a joke they're trying to
[ __ ] shut me down right now
they don't like what and i have i think
they like the language is less of a
problem than the fact that i'm doing it
independently and put it on myself sure
i think that's the
first piece of the action they're like
you know why don't you come to this big
[ __ ] label and i'm like [ __ ] that up
i wanna because if i were you when i
needed you dog where were you when i
came in and you told me that that
wouldn't sell
that that wouldn't get radio play get
the [ __ ] out of here where were you you
know you showed up when i had a million
heads
anybody could show up when you had a
million [ __ ] downloads and and the
record is uh yeah i know i met like
i met with those [ __ ] dudes how about
one version where you say instead of
[ __ ] you [ __ ] how about miss you girl
i'm like that's not what i'm saying what
i'm trying to say yeah no no no they
have listen
they don't understand the power of the
internet today
they don't understand that
and i don't want to harp on this
but it's a reality
the first 90 days trump had him
by talking the truth
this country's ready
for the language it's part of the
country
that's still not ready you know they're
trying to make believe they don't know
what we're talking about like you don't
[ __ ] your [ __ ] secretary in the ass
behind your wife's back but if i say tit
you get offended go [ __ ] yourself
you know what i'm saying you're banging
your [ __ ] babysitter you disgusting
[ __ ] savage
but if i say suck my dick on stage you
actually go back and ask for your ten
dollars back you measly [ __ ] yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy those are the people that
pissed me the [ __ ] off that they're
gonna they're here this is what i'm
surrounded with
yeah it's [ __ ] [ __ ] because i'm
like why can't because i had that
argument with my new record i was
talking about and
again not to get on this like
i i watch meet the press in the morning
on nbc and they're talking about and
they're showing a clip of the
president talking about grabbing [ __ ]
why can't i play [ __ ] you [ __ ] on the
radio play [ __ ] king on the [ __ ]
radio and you know don't even argue with
them go okay
yeah don't worry i'll come with you and
what happens what i didn't realize
before i turned out smarter than i
thought it was an accident i was like
well then don't you can't have it when
you say you can't have it no everybody
wants it
yeah it's really crazy how even with the
podcast well now now agents are starting
but all their advice
is bad
all their advice is bad
they have a couple good things that they
pop up with
that you could independently test on
your own without them if you catch my
drift
but their ideas
they just want to burn you up
you know after this next album number
two the second arm you put out and it
hits number one again the whole thing i
hope it does no knock on what it is it
will it will because we need this right
now
yeah well that was my that's my goal is
i've never cared about the church but
i'm like
i want a number one country record just
to [ __ ] try to [ __ ] with them no
listen remember you said no here you go
you know madonna years ago ten years ago
raffled off all her rejection letters
they said people running for the hills
and she read them this is what lisayet
said president of icom you're a
worthless [ __ ] you'll never work in
this town you know
she said who said that no it's like uh
madonna read all her rejection letters
from back in the day with the rank rip
the record executive said and where they
are today
and people who said she couldn't sing
and all that [ __ ] she raffled them off
for charity years ago something weird to
do because every i think every artist
has the same thing as
people think you know
like you watch them on tv it's like oh
they got so much money they don't care
but you take it more personally than
[ __ ] anybody
you know like i understand keeping all
your rejection letters i still got you
know
i remember every [ __ ] who told
me i couldn't this album wouldn't sell
or i couldn't do what i was doing i
remember like i know their face i know
their name i know their family i know
everything yeah you remember for the
rest of your life yeah you never forget
it and you know what's crazy
that when you get to a certain level you
want to walk up to them and rub it in
their face but at that time
you go you know what i want and he knows
it there's nothing he could do he could
look me in the eye
and now he can tell me how he's going to
book me
you know what i'm saying he needs to
book me and how he's missed me and how
he always believed in me it's amazing i
was the only one who believed in you
yeah and you know what you like
i could be the type of guy that could go
go [ __ ] yourself there's some people who
have said that to
but there's some people who you know
what remember a couple of years ago you
didn't want to pay me
one night you got a baby yeah i'm not
that i send i'm with you i tend not to
not yeah you cannot you cannot hold the
grudge because somebody didn't
pay attention because you were a little
older or because you're fat or something
like that it's amazing i right now i
talked to our friend tommy easton
and tommy is a funny guy from the south
just like you
uh
he doesn't understand
what i see like when tommy is from
atlanta
and he's country you know what i'm
saying yeah so when he walks into this
improv and this communist on these
places they look at you weird so i said
to him eliminate that
go get a commercial agent
you're a country boy you're going to
book every [ __ ] country boy
commercial they shoot
and then you walk in there and it's
completely different ball game yeah i
got an offer for a big commercial i'm so
[ __ ] pissed about it yeah i said they
took it back i'm saying that's why i'm
so pissed
but they won this it was like it was i
won't say the name of the company some
burger chain they had this new [ __ ]
uh like bourbon bacon
burger you know with like burger with
like [ __ ]
it was a burger with like [ __ ]
bourbon and cheat yeah [ __ ] just [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know right that
pigs [ __ ] whatever in it yeah
i was like barbecue sauce that's like
eating [ __ ]
[ __ ] sperm sauce and they're like and
they were like we don't think you do but
if you know you know how to sell it i
said [ __ ] take them i'm like yeah i'm
in and they can't i think they probably
heard this didn't listen to the record
but that's how crazy i was that was it
and then they then also next thing i
know the [ __ ] um
commercial deal is done but i would i
was ready to sell out right there
you know i can just imagine
when they those four guys hit
the the country dudes years ago how are
people you know the dude uh yeah my my
hometown ron white and then
lingvall and
you know larry the cable guy you know
larry the cable guy changed his persona
and stuff like that whatever but
i could just see people going that's not
going to work they're ready yeah my [ __ ]
you it's not going to work my hometown
is they have a rupp arena which is where
the kentucky plays basketball 23 000
people
jeff foxworthy comes in sells out the
[ __ ] place with a microphone the gig
probably costs him 20 dollars and he
makes a [ __ ] million bucks flies
his own personal plan so we were we were
talking earlier about how like maybe a
lot of people in different places don't
listen to country or don't really
understand the south why are there
people like you and jeff fox like jeff
foxworthy i had his cd up in boston yeah
no way i've never been to the south i
had his cd because that's where it goes
back to what i was saying before in
kentucky you didn't listen to it because
it was like wasn't cool
well it was local [ __ ] you know
i watched hee haw
when i came from cuba religiously
and i got it i liked it i enjoyed it
i didn't know i was going to end up
marrying hee haw
you know what i'm saying but that's not
the goal of the show oh no no i'm
married listen
my the first time i took my niece to
dinner in nashville me and my wife my
niece and the baby we went and we got
went to jimmy d's this little
medium range steakhouse no big deal
my
my niece asked me if she should get the
gun
because when we valet park the man was
taking your car
that's how countries he is damn
that country my wife is [ __ ] country
jack and all she needs to do is call her
parents in the morning for the first
hour i live with hee haw
then once she takes the kid to school
and goes back to ralph it smoothens out
for a little while back to regular tv
yeah right the right to regular
programming people but he all gets a bad
rap but i'll tell you what they they got
some killer music
i watched all those things
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah some of that great i mean
great guitar playing too it's like they
had to ruin it with some of those lame
jokes but i mean
i heard they were bringing it back and i
was like
that's like
i heard they're bringing it back i was
like i want to host the new here then i
realized it would be [ __ ] so they still
do man tv or they canceled it i think
they just brought it back they brought
it back but they didn't cancel it i
don't think so maybe i can check no adam
ray's on it amir k i didn't hear
anything else about it
but no you never know yeah you're right
they probably bring back key hall with
somebody puerto rican they just brought
back uh cash cab without ben bailey i
don't know if you saw that no they did
yeah they're bringing it back and doing
like a celebrity version it's gonna be
terrible
i hate that [ __ ] what's the name what
was the show that they just put on
netflix um
the kids the show that was on when i was
a kid um
popeye no no the the sitcom the uh
the with uh with the uh
the olsen twins
full house yeah i was like that [ __ ]
show [ __ ] sucked when i was a kid why
they bring it like it's like nostalgic
and cool to bring it back [ __ ] you we
don't want to watch [ __ ]
people some people do some people do
obviously it did well i mean i was like
everyone was like on the internet was
like all excited it's coming back i was
like dude no you didn't watch that
[ __ ] try sitting through that show
now it's the worst [ __ ] [ __ ]
half the show is you watching that
you're like what how the [ __ ] did i
watch this what's the thing is i'll turn
you all into this e3 you or every show
you you watch it 10 years later you're
like this
is [ __ ] i'll turn it on
like just to get motivated sometimes
i'll turn on like you know
country like the hit country radio
station i'm like this is [ __ ] hip-hop
this is
rednecks rapping over hip-hop beats like
i'd rather listen to nwa i'm not gonna
listen to [ __ ] this [ __ ] shitty
country band trying to right now your
music taste is very broad
you love everything i love everything
yeah yeah yeah i mean i grew up probably
on it to be honest because i was
rebelling against where i was from i
grew up on probably more rock probably
listen to the sabbath and all that
[ __ ] uh you know zeppelin and
everything
and then i got into
like i said when you kind of go out it's
like no no a friend will play you
wailing you'll be like no no that's my
music it's you take
you take authorship of it later but who
were your early influences
[Music]
well
me and the the guy who produced my
records who's amazing by the way we had
the same we both agree a bunch of my
friends agreed it all starts with the
beatles for us i don't know if you dug
the beatles but like
literally the first time i i heard
i bet the first buck owen song i heard
was ringo singing act naturally
you the cool thing about the beatles was
you could
you could listen to it and hear every
type you could hear chuck berry you
could hear
rest in peace you could hear
helter skelter was basically in metal
you could hear
like almost opera kind of and or i mean
classical music a little bit and like
you know eleanor rigby or you could hear
country like i said they would play a
lot of country almost like a
they did like uh
carl perkins [ __ ] you mean you could you
could hear every type of music did you
like the whole discography of the eagle
uh the beatles
yeah i liked it at home yes
the early [ __ ] drives me crazy i'm with
you i mean i don't have like 66 on like
that album and all that music uh
revolver and the whiteout rubber sole
and rubber sole and the one when they
they went to india
they went to india
they said no uh
with the [ __ ] heart uh what the thing
sergeant pepper
i like sergeant pepe as well magical
mystery like
i'm on the borderline to help
help with your help help i like that
song yeah but help but i have to help
i like everything
is brilliant i will say that i'm i'm
with you
i don't find myself listening to early
beatles now you know no no no it's like
it sounds like kind of
almost teeny bopper music but you know
what i i [ __ ] listen to music a lot
and you broadened me tonight when you
said
that the beatles covered everything
because i got to tell you something as
soon as you said that i heard
the chords to she loves you yeah yeah
yeah the beginning of it
and i was like oh [ __ ] he's right i've
heard that before
i have heard that before maybe somebody
took it from them or not in the the same
chord the same dynamic and not that
stuff
but just that twang and the chord
that uh
john lennon had or george harrison was
the real catalyst there with the guitar
but
people don't know the beatles anymore
the beatles don't even [ __ ] matter
people have no
kids are growing up
and hear three beatles songs on the
radio and they don't understand
what to be those men i feel like when i
was a kid i don't know if you guys tell
me but i feel like when i was a kid
maybe
that timing was like the beatles were
kind of cool but elvis was like
oldies music and i feel like beetles are
not turning into holidays but the
problem with the beatles is that unless
you grew up with a generation that your
parents played the beatles and my
parents played a lot if you're lost in
the beatles
all you know about the beatles is the
radio
the songs on the radio you really never
put the whole
you never put on uh
rubber soul or [ __ ] what's what's not
tomorrow tomorrow never knows god that's
the best [ __ ] song that's from uh
that's from a revolver revolver
yeah they haven't listened to revolver
they don't understand
the whole the changes those
[ __ ] made you know how a band
can't stay together and have three
albums how many albums that these
savages have just estimate give me
someone told someone told me that
from the time
they started to when they broke up
they put out the their whole career
lasted the same amount that u2 takes
between records that's what someone told
me that you too
the band you too you know they usually
on average they said they take like six
seven years
to
make a new record that's how long the
whole beatles career was that's it
yeah their plane landed in um
in new york is when when people first
heard of them was 63 they broke up in
70. their whole career was seven years
and how many albums they put out ask
them i mean probably ten i mean pro
maybe more but well it's weird because
they had 12 um they put out a different
amount and
their albums were different in england
than here some of them so it's hard to
say the exact amount but you just said
it 12. if you
if you didn't listen to the beatles what
would you recommend somebody to start
with
what album well it would matter no
matter who the person was i would say i
think what you we just came across
revolver is a good one that's kind of
got a little bit of everything
i would actually you know what ozzie's
favorite album of all time is is why the
wide album the white arm is brilliant
the white album is great because you can
again as an example if you can get
everything
i mean helter skelter is more metal than
most [ __ ] you or more hard rock than
most [ __ ] you'll hear nowadays
then you've got little ballads and weird
[ __ ] ringo [ __ ] it's all over the
place
no no it's it
nobody really listens when i was growing
up
people were really into the beatles and
then when john lennon died like a whole
[ __ ] error people went away because
that's what they were holding on to
that's what they were holding on to is
the beatles get back together seriously
i was i was 17.
he got shot yeah
and i still remember going to new york
that sunday
and
at the time i was going to be the guy
bro at the time i did not want to listen
to the beatles and springsteen
i was not interested
i was a zeppelin sabbath
i was i was against the beatles because
so many people liked the beatles it
drove me [ __ ] bananas
and then years later in colorado
was when i got 66 to do whatever
i'm like wait a second these [ __ ]
won to something
and then i want the one you mentioned
tomorrow never know that's true that's
my all-time favorite that's a [ __ ]
killer it's brilliant
you're on acid in that song they brought
the acid to you that was the first time
you ever tripped
the first time you heard that i think i
don't know you have to check me i think
that was the first time john lennon took
acid maybe
well they went to india or something i
don't know i'm not a big historian no
because i i'm a big beatles historian
they um
i heard uh um
the beatles were at a party in l.a or
something and they took acid for the
first time and uh
oh there's a song she said you know that
one yeah she said i know i know what
it's like to be dead is uh
henry fonda
they were all an asset at some party
henry fonda walked up to john lennon
goes i know what it's like to be dead
and john lennon just took it and put it
in that song
yeah that's yeah those old [ __ ] party
days you know
no a lot of people don't even
i would yeah i would listen to revolver
the white album
i definitely get letter b
yeah and then we're letting b start off
as their worst album i think it's one of
the best no i i like it i like the frame
you know i haven't had the physical beat
albums which now i'm going to start
going and buying physical beat albums
next time i go to burbank i'm going to
buy some physical beetle alarms it's
time you're absolutely right i've
neglected them over the years well i got
you back into it well it's important to
on a podcast to
sell some beatles records um
it's funny because i'm trying to do a
podcast right now it's kind of falling
apart but i did i'm doing like call-in
guests and i was talking to bill burr
who's the [ __ ] funniest guy ever he
was a wheeler fan so i'm like maybe
he'll do the podcast he was nice enough
to call in
who knows this podcast will ever come
out but i was telling him he's like
talking about
want
like
young
artists like what they should be into
i just got this uh
there's like 30-something disc set of uh
dylan on tour with the
with the band and 66
playing the most killer rock and roll
you ever heard
and uh getting booed off the [ __ ]
stage every night i don't know if you
remember that
no
but uh he put when he went from folk to
electric they [ __ ] booed him on stage
and i've got
someone for my birthday last year gave
me
it's a it's a it's a box set of every
every show they played on that tour and
every show
dylan starts folk acoustic and then they
move the band comes on and they play
electric
and you've never heard killer music like
this and they get food
it's like keys helps keep things in
perspective you know
first of all
the band yeah is one of the best bands
yeah that's people don't know about
that's another thing people you know i
played them one time and people insulted
me
yeah i feel like they don't get their
duel all the time listen neil young
doesn't exist anymore
what is that noise
it's going
legacy
no it's not nothing you see it's
something in that thing that's why i
told you to lower this lower the mics a
little bit can you get a little closer
uh no no just lower the mics a little
bit even if i'm far away look i'm far
away right here and they can hear it
lower the mics a little bit okay there
you go because that thing's buzzing the
[ __ ] out you're
are you listening over there what are
you maybe hey listen you saw him he
almost [ __ ] died yeah i know i know
that a little bit he's probably hearing
that on his own is that yeah how you
doing man i'm doing good he's ready for
another bunker that's important yeah i
don't know if i want to watch though
sure you want everybody wants to watch
lee do another bangla he's panicking
already and [ __ ] he forgets
that we get the weed that killed lucifer
you [ __ ] forget you don't train on
and i know you got wheat at your house
don't tell me you don't i have a weight
at the house you have at least a half
what are you doing
what happened do you only smoke here is
that the deal i eat edibles at home but
i don't smoke at home really his
girlfriend would beat him oh my god i
smell i smoke all the time he doesn't
smoosh him
i talk only i took one or two hits of
this and i'm [ __ ]
small about to die if he went on the
balcony tonight
his girlfriend would beat him [ __ ]
senseless everyone out there and smoking
right now
he has no idea
when i'm when he's over here he's ten
thousand stars and he's over there i
thought 13.50
i ate sixteen hundred
when on seven tonight i don't know
you better eat those stones yeah when i
said i was coming on here i got eight
million tweets like watch the [ __ ]
death stars man what's the stars of
death and shards of death yes well you
don't why you're not training tonight
what do you think we forgot about this
i've been trying wow you
half the bag now because you only got
500 milligrams in it only that's nothing
you could that's a walk in the park
that's a good amount it's a different
one no one has when you told the li the
girl at the store that someone had two
of the tko she almost passed out no she
didn't see nothing you could do two two
gals and you just leave like ten of
those just to balance you out you got
like 10 ready to rock look at you
you got to keep crying this is peer
pressure man this is he's a [ __ ]
savage but he don't want to train no
more
come on man don't get soft on me i
wouldn't i would never do that to you
wheeler thanks dude
don't even get me started on the
periscope debacle if you think the kelly
assassination is [ __ ] up you don't
want to hear about the periscope the
bach what was the periscope about well
he fake stars made him double how dare
you all right wheeler and i call him on
the wall i want to figure this out he
doesn't get high i call him a two he's
over there singing songs watching parks
and rec
and then the next day i give him 10
stars here and you thought he saw the
[ __ ] the devil
uh he was here till four in the morning
he barfed he ordered pizza i didn't barf
no not that night he ordered pizza have
you taken enough edibles to barf
what are you waiting for you keep
telling
accusing me you just empty the goddamn
bag
you ain't [ __ ] come on man yeah
you're playing games what's the problem
here
you ate 500 milligrams of tk that don't
do nothing to you sure it doesn't do
anything you got to mix them
what's those last two in your hand i
can't i don't stick eight of these put
five in your mouth and drink it let
these intestines do the rest that's what
i do that's why i don't chew them
just throw them in your mouth and drink
the water over them and watch it no
you're not one of those [ __ ] you
choose is it yeah he and then he gets
sick and that's why i try to tell him
just drink the eat the whole store hole
how are you doing just to swallow this
thing this thing i can eat three of
those [ __ ] things what just throw
them in your mouth and just drink the
juice after it and watch what happens
let the intestines do the work
poorly man please a savage of death
this is what he does on the weekends
they go they hold hands he eats one star
he tells people he ate 13 milligrams
[ __ ] man is he getting borrowed from him
no i'm not gonna burn him
trust me you'll know i'll make a noise
i know i'll know but i don't know we did
a podcast last week on wednesday i must
have got 20 [ __ ]
things about all the noises he made that
night
like when he gets really high you'll
hear little noises that's probably what
the noise was
that's his stomach yeah he's [ __ ] no
he only ate the turkey my intestines
burning he didn't he didn't well he
hasn't the audience missed it but right
before went on this guy i've never seen
a cough like this this dude coughed for
[ __ ] 30 minutes that's why when was
the last time you had a transmission
fluid
ah it's been a few weeks yeah and so
you're used to these
so yeah so i'm not used to these no
you're used to the star one because you
haven't gone out what did you choke on
was it the pipe or the bomb i choked the
bong he he likes putting all the dark
wheat underneath it what's the dot
what's the dark weight that we did
everyone says [ __ ] darkness it is
it's the one that everyone's already
smoked and that's why that's why you i
don't know how you don't call all right
well i'm gonna fill up a brand new weed
for you right now so you'll see i want
to know what the black wheat is
the black wheat is what he calls smoked
weed like if you think how is that worse
it's the same [ __ ] don't listen to him
yeah lee you're [ __ ] me up why do you
listen to him he confuses people um he
confuses the people i thought he was
all you need
that's all you need to know right there
you know what i'm saying that's all you
need
he confuses the people on periscope
this is brand new [ __ ] wheat check
this out
go ahead
there you go
all right go for broccoli this is the
one that killed abdullah
nah nah nah lee lee lee because then
he's gonna complain that it's dark weed
no i'm not yes he is he's gonna complain
i'm gonna cough you just took it out of
my [ __ ] mouth dead anyways let me put
some more water on this you don't need
no water because you're gonna flood it
it's perfect however yeah you can
perfect don't touch nothing you can
cough plenty off yeah don't touch
nothing in fact
you left drooling there before so you
gained an ounce oh gross no i'm only
teasing you go ahead hit that [ __ ]
soldier it's
it's monday that's the end of [ __ ]
march that's it
that's it
there you go oh [ __ ] is he gonna do it
again oh please this is the one that
killed losers
oh here we go
now now he turns the bars down
this [ __ ] dude oh
jesus christ
[Laughter]
you're gonna kill this [ __ ]
this is what happened before that has
been playing for years
yeah
at least you know the ending to this
most podcasts don't have an ending oh
yeah yeah
that's the total one we're gonna shoot
heroin for new year's eve and you're
gonna get a nurse to come in here excuse
me how long it'll take you to convince
him to do heroin i'm gonna say four
minutes
i'm not going heroin
put it in a [ __ ] in a gummy form
he'll treat it he won't know he wasn't
hilarious he's my dog he knows i love
him he [ __ ] around i get him we that
sustain training
when i go out of town hit this before
you go to the gym just one time he don't
smoke he don't listen so that's what
happens he turns pro you see that before
yeah i saw i saw drool down to his phone
oh it was hysterical he was done but
he's all right now he bet what's what's
going on with those stars i hate three
star i i think i'm okay three stars
don't do nothing that's 850.
what's that going to do to you that
doesn't even give you a headache it's
not even worth the gelatin you might as
well kill that bag you're a soldier it's
monday night come on man monday night
you said the
listen monday night you set the [ __ ]
door even how you drank tonight i drink
one beer i get [ __ ] hammered i got no
alcohol resistance i'll drink another
one and do it for a [ __ ] wheeler put
us out yeah don't if you're not doing it
for yourself do it for the south for
kentucky yeah do it for kentucky someday
you're going to go to kentucky and
they're going to see you on the street
and go you're lisayet you ate a bunch of
snails like jews in kentucky they got
tons of them tons oh please they're all
over the place they even got a cuban
restaurant in lexington
what is it i don't know
yeah look at that i'll check it out
it's by the college it's a fun little
place
it smells a little greasy but it does
the trick i'm just trying to think about
they fried bananas and [ __ ] in there so
they keep inside the what's it called
plantains
yeah they're good i love that [ __ ] yeah
but they got four cuban restaurants
supposedly in
louisville yeah i don't go to louisville
much do you play there in louisville
yeah we actually though my last tour
right before i did record the new record
i got
i never really toured much and i [ __ ]
i got i got [ __ ] lead i got i got so
sick i'd never been on the road that
long and i think it's just too much
many nights of getting [ __ ] up and
yeah make some more noise with that
[ __ ] bag guys yeah turn it upside
down and go like this with your fingers
all the way to the finger bang it and
they'll fall out but you're working
against the gravity there you go all the
way to the valley emerson college five
[ __ ] years there you go
there you go
they were stuck at the top i had the
finger but that's what the noise was
with me fingerboard
let me show you
five
that's all you need that's something the
party's done how many did you eat
already this is all
seven seven that's it another
seven that's it man sure dude eat the
bag eat the bag eat the bag it's tuesday
night that's it it's easter you're the
anti lent how'd it become tuesday all of
a sudden because by the time you wake up
it'll be tuesday yeah that's what i'm
saying you'll be fine
now what's different to you between
louisville and like lexington louisville
is a big city compared to lexington yeah
i mean i think uh
like you were saying before it's all
it's
south is so sports oriented you know
it's like
you ten you hate louisville when you're
in lexington because you hate the
cardinals and you love the wildcats
which doesn't happen out here you know
it's like it's all sports related you
hate [ __ ] patino you know
but you love ca it's very um
there's probably a um
there's a um
what's the word i'm looking you got me
two [ __ ] stone well you know they
they go at each other you know it's like
oh you're louisville guy now lexington
ain't good enough you know so i don't
know i don't i don't go to louisville
that much because
it didn't seem like an enough of a step
oh you know it's like it's
a little bit it's like the same city now
is this the first time you're gonna be
performing in new york or you performed
in new york before we did one show in
new york on the last tour it was good it
was it was a real it was a real small
place
it was like 250 people and we sold it
out pretty fast and this one's i think
twice as big hopefully we can sell it i
don't know but like i said i [ __ ]
even then in this last tour i [ __ ]
flipped out
well that's what we would get into that
right now your second album's coming out
it'll be successful i hope you're right
and all of a sudden your agent will call
you and say listen
it's time to get a bus
and do a 12-week tour
and you know
you and your guys are excited you know
and you do it and listen
right away i'm crying because i
shouldn't be [ __ ] crying people like
led zeppelin not even led zeppelin black
sabbath went on the road for like three
years and recorded on the road didn't
they i mean they were [ __ ] animals
they didn't stop well i know guys would
do that thing yeah they don't stop that
[ __ ] that's the thing is that bus
costs [ __ ] 20 grand a day i mean if i
have friends who have those big buses
but
you got to make good money to pay you
you have to make a lot of money at cover
expenses
that bus is so [ __ ] expensive and you
know people don't realize how hard the
road is you know like how hard it is
when you're a kid it sounds like [ __ ] no
when you're a kid it's like nothing when
you're a kid you can do anything eight
nights a [ __ ] week
you know when you're a kid you can sleep
on a couch and nothing happens what's up
what's the longest you've gone on the
road as a [ __ ]
november to april
well that's pretty [ __ ] long without
going home at all no i would send
clothes home and i did that three times
when i moved to los angeles in 98 i
found holes in my game
and i pretty much stayed out from
98 what do you mean by holes in your
game
i just had holes in my game man like i
wasn't and you went out i was funny
but i didn't really get the concept of
the set and a bunch of little things i
got put in between nick apollo and doug
stanhope and i ate a bag of dicks and i
had to walk off the stage and watch
both of them destroy well and i said you
know what i need to get seasoned i need
to
get some legs under me
so i would do an old-school style i
would just like book five out of six
weeks
have like a week off
and i'd go and from there i start
and could you feel it like
oh i'm getting i'm i'm better now like
oh when i come back here six seven
months later yeah
because i do a combination of everything
i do a combination of one nighters
which toughens your skin
and i do good rooms to shave off the fat
that's smart so because what happens if
you do a bunch of one-nighters and come
here you're gonna have to shave off that
fat eventually from different spots
uh you like let's say i'm from nashville
right i got 35 minutes but i got 15
minutes on nashville that [ __ ] don't
work
in tupelo mississippi come on so you
just lost 15 minutes chap so you better
hip hop and start penciling those 15.
it's funny cuz i did i did carol this
morning and i
they want us to perform live i did a
song live as like my voice sounded like
[ __ ] because i hadn't been on the road
or been in the studio forever
and there's nothing there's no training
you can do other than just playing on
just going out and playing for five
months that's the only training you can
have
but the the my singing on the new record
to me sounded awesome because i was i'd
just gotten off the road from
four months on the road
i was like how do i get my voice back to
that shape you just got to go yes i
would go back and stop no there's no
there's no warm ups or anything no you
can do the exercises i know that
vocalists do certain exercises yeah i
have my goose and work
doesn't do work
but even that it's nothing is com close
to
being just doing yeah the timing
the audience the exposure no no no it's
and that's
i knew to get better you couldn't
do hip crowds
you know when you first start off comedy
you want to do new york and
vegas and los angeles
but
you really have to learn how to perform
in buffalo on a cold night
you got to really learn how to perform
in uh
uh indiana what so what's your biggest
city sorry if i'm asking the questions
but like what's your what's your best
city like where do you do the best
by podcast standards
san francisco
no but like as far as getting a crowd to
your shows oh anywhere where this
podcast reaches we'll get a crowd
these people are [ __ ] savages really
yeah these people are savages
reaches everywhere
i've done shows in paducah and i've had
people [ __ ] show up in little padooka
which is great
i've done shows in jackson had 60 70
people show up they've driven it from
nashville or
you know that's how you start getting
the big audiences when they drive yeah
you know
nashville i get good numbers
but
you have to learn how to cut your teeth
in those little towns and you have to
learn how to how for me to wake you up
at eight in the morning and go we look
come on
we got a 10-hour drive to our next city
well i remember the the first night of
my first tour
we had a we had a 5 a.m radio interview
i woke up at 11.
and i called up the radio station i'm
like are we late
can we still come in i'm like they're
like you're [ __ ] six hours late
there's been three shows since you've
[ __ ] the show you made and you're
never allowed on this radio station
again like i don't give a [ __ ] yeah once
you burn the bridge you're done [ __ ]
them like [ __ ] this station but i that
sleep was more important to me than any
[ __ ] radio station well you know this
is it like this
this week i got to get up at four
the car picks me up at 4 30. for what to
go to the airport i get to the airport i
fly to new york
[ __ ] thursday morning i gotta do
radio at 8 00 a.m which is 5 a.m late
time it's crazy and then friday
i'm probably gonna have to do something
and saturday you sleep all day because
my sunday my saturday night flight
i gotta be there at [ __ ] uh
i think like 4 45
back here no i got to be at kennedy
airport by 4 45 the flight just back
here yeah so i'm pretty much getting off
stage going back to the room laying down
for an hour
i'll be packed and everything and i get
right in the [ __ ] car and i'm back
here
i mean it's a life but it's kind of
tough i only do it twice a month okay
okay i'm 54. i gotta take care of myself
that [ __ ] every week that they call you
with and go you have to go there i don't
have to do nothing i just got a call
that i'm playing vegas this weekend they
sent me a flyer i'm like what the [ __ ]
you there's a picture there's a flyer of
me with these two girls on it
where's the band who should like who
[ __ ] booked what the [ __ ] going on
did your agent contact you
i heard i heard rumors of it but i heard
i saw the flyer way before i agreed
right so nobody confirmed they just oh
yeah they said to offer you what do you
think you said i'm available we'll call
you back and awesome there's a flyer
and there's tickets being sold i have no
[ __ ] i got to check up on them yeah no
that's that's how fast this goes yeah it
moves [ __ ] fast you know
it's funny because before we came on the
podcast
we were talking about scams people who
and then i fell from one of the other i
it
we were talking about how dumb do you
have to be are we getting dumber you
know like what the [ __ ] is going on you
know which we never really answered we
said we're gonna answer on the podcast
i don't know if we're getting dumber i
think we're putting a lot of trust in
the internet yeah at times i don't even
like purchasing my wife handles all that
stuff
but i don't type numbers into a [ __ ]
thing yeah what i was saying is i got an
email the other day and
saying that one of my email passwords
was uh
someone said that i needed to change it
so i checked click on the email that's
my name i put it in they asked my email
address i put it and then they
asked my
um for my credit card information i was
about i seriously taken my credit card
out
i was about to type it and i go you know
what
there's no
email
place that needs your credit card to
change your email password and i could
put it down
like know it's like
i was that close to being that one of
those [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] and
you know you're not you're never that
[ __ ] far away well you have to think
about lee said he got the call from the
irs people yeah i got that a couple of
years like the first year that i didn't
have a job
they called me and they said uh it was
like an automated message and like
contact your uh representative or we
recommend you get an attorney
uh you owe such and such to the irs and
i got paranoid but luckily now with
google you just look it up and they and
like the irs even has a thing on their
website that says
uh
we will never call you it's always going
to be through the mail
because so many they just they just
busted one of the places in india what
what were they trying to do to you they
they want you to uh they probably call
you and want to like have you pay what
you supposedly order the irs or
immediately or the cops are going to
come to your house in the restroom right
children they had the scam on 2020 in
one of those 60 minutes
it's
[ __ ] mind-boggling
mind-boggling how much money people sent
like without even [ __ ] thinking like
really
those those junk mail things like you
were saying before we went on the air
was like
you only need a few people to send in
some checks
listen
i tell this story
this is one of the greatest stories i've
ever heard about the america because
it's like when i was a kid there was a a
guy named peter lemongello
nobody ever heard of peter learned in
general
but abc late night had a commercial the
best of peter lemongello
999
disguise things all the songs
don't mean who peter lemon jello is what
the [ __ ] peter lemon that's what i'm
saying
can you please look up who the [ __ ]
peter loving jello is
i'll never forget this peter lemingelo
was this singer that nobody knew about
him also they had the best of peter
living jello
and he covered six or seven songs
and like it was the biggest scam of all
[ __ ] time oh he wasn't was he made it
i think i have the commercial
play yeah this is [ __ ] crazy
but they did this other thing
this i watched this on like some tv show
15 years ago like hbo late night this
dildo company
put an ad out
and they would have
and it wasn't playboy it wasn't another
high-level porno more magazines it was
like a medium level one with chicks show
their [ __ ] and [ __ ] like that
and the back page they had this dildo
that came with water
and steam and smoke and no batteries you
charged it
they must have had it was 24.95 they
must have had
2 000 orders
the first three months or something
weird and then a couple thousand after
that
what this company did they didn't even
have them till though
didn't even have a dogo
they would take your money
put in the bank and then cut you back a
check
that said
we don't have
yeah
but the check says it's from a dildo
company no they have a dildo on the
check
this is way before the atm machine you
know what i'm saying
you wouldn't go in and you you're too
embarrassed yeah who's gonna cast this
check well dildo that's a [ __ ] genius
so they made [ __ ] millions they
banged people out and some people
reported it but this was peter
lemongello look at this
[Music]
you are about to witness a new dimension
in entertainment
[Music]
peter lemon jealousy
[Music]
76
yes peter lemongello has created a new
kind of music that's both romantic and
moving
[Music]
this guy not really even exist no
nobody played nobody's ever heard of
peter 11 [ __ ] i know a lot about
music i never felt no nobody ever knew
about people they just put it out there
at night and they figured it cost them
nothing to [ __ ] get the commercial
were there songs on it yeah like songs
like he looked he had one song they
probably wrote maybe just covers and the
worst is like that dude in vegas who the
[ __ ] goes to see that guy singing
people's songs
the guy from vacation i would never go
see that [ __ ] guy in a million years
which guy is that
that dude who [ __ ] the mother in vegas
what's his name that's been there for
2000 years
he thinks he's obvious he was elvis
elvis used to bit slap wayne newton oh
yeah with that [ __ ] costume on i'm
going to pay 20 hours to see wayne
newton sing [ __ ]
by tom jones songs get the [ __ ] out of
here i don't have time for that [ __ ]
but this was all the little
i call them american ingenuity scams
and they still it's [ __ ] smart to do
that no when you go yeah and i went to i
took my date out to dinner on my wife my
date i took my wife out to dinner
so we had to walk to the mall so i go
listen on the way out we'll get mercy
shoes here the baby get a pair of
sneakers they had sneakers there
when we stood online i saw all those
things that they sell on tv late night
so you know we have stores of them i see
on tv oh yeah what do you call that [ __ ]
uh as seen on tv no no it has something
for your wrist that you'll never use
you know like like the biggest scam of
all time is to self-massage it
you're never going to use it there's no
self-massaging i got to stretch my arm
to get the bottom of my [ __ ] back i'm
twisting my shoulder to massage that gun
that anything's going to work none of
those things work but though avatar you
know the the cop and knee brace
that [ __ ] comes on at nine o'clock at
night fat people are there you know what
if i get that cup of knee brace maybe
i'll exercise no you won't but you'll
drop to 23.95 that [ __ ] don't work that
copper [ __ ] knee brace no i had one
of those i didn't order from there
somebody gave it to you i've already got
that shot i've ordered that [ __ ] on
[ __ ] tv though what's the thing you
put in your door that you do yeah yeah
and what happened well no i was i was
stoned and i had taken an ambien i woke
up the next morning there's a [ __ ]
box in my door two days later there's a
box in my door with a [ __ ] pull-up
machine i'd use i've ta i've literally
done one pull-up in six years
no you don't use none of that [ __ ] yeah
you're never gonna use all that buying
stuff you're never gonna use another
apparently when i was [ __ ] up i
thought i needed to get you know now
does ambien really make you black out
like that no yeah no i forget [ __ ] yeah
booze or just straight i don't straight
i don't i try not to mix it with booze
it's not good for you but um
when i take it yeah i'll [ __ ]
what will happen is i'll wake up the
next morning and there'll be a text from
a girl it's like you know
what time tonight and i'll read through
the texts i'll be like
a girl i haven't talked to for years
like
we should we should hang out
i was on ambi i don't remember i was
like
me and you it's like this friendship why
are we friends we need to take it to the
next level i like i get this [ __ ] uh
like i get really cocky on ambien i
guess and i wake up and i gotta you know
it's almost like i should take ambien to
take her out
to be back to that guy you know it's
like uh
i act like a you know
i just start texting girls on the fall
[ __ ] i don't remember it at all
they said people have bought cars and
cooked meals oh i believe that yeah
and not knowing what the [ __ ] the next
day they've woken up in there i think my
subconscious wanting [ __ ] maybe
oh everybody's subconscious wants [ __ ]
as soon as you you smoke a joint in your
late night you want a piece of ass
you're like yeah i think that ambient
like i said the next morning it's just
my phone is a bunch of text of
from all the night before it's like
speaking of uh scams the have you do you
guys ever get worried about the credit
card ones like the machines oh
do you check i don't i don't care i pull
them out i hit them at the gas station i
cover the [ __ ] number because there's
people with telescopes you got to assume
oh yeah what are you going to assume you
got to assume all that [ __ ] when you go
to a store and you stick your credit
card listen when you stick your credit
card in the machine you're doomed
it's like we were discussing uh
you ever go to an airline southwest any
airline and they say put your id in or
your credit card everything's in your
credit card
date of birth address
how old your kid is everything's in that
[ __ ] credit card so when you put them
at the gas stations and all that [ __ ]
every time you use that out like i have
a work credit card
and then i have a credit card
they could steal the word credit card
you ain't going to get dick out of that
that goes in small increments that's why
that's why i have to i have a word
credit card and then i have one that i
use or restaurants or whatever the [ __ ]
but i have a work credit card and then
we have one universe what were you
talking about covering it up what was
that you cover it up you when you hit
the numbers you always got to be [ __ ]
safe especially today there's always
some [ __ ] that's cute
or you have to assume have you seen the
videos of them putting the the they have
machines that look like they're machines
and they just they put it on and it fits
right on and it just has a little chip
and it transmits all the data it's crazy
where is it where do they have those
atm machines and stores yeah like a
basically a fake atm you put it in the
machine on top that's why when you
before you stick your card in always
grab that thing and pull it out oh [ __ ]
i know
listen every time you go to vegas
within two months you're gonna charge
from vegas
i don't know how they do it
i know people go to vegas and two weeks
later their account has cleaned that
and you think back where did you go you
went to vegas
all those things in vegas because
everybody who goes to vegas you're
either going to gamble or to scam people
out of that money
more reason to cancel that gig
no you got to go to vegas and do the gig
but when you go to vegas you got to be
very careful
you know i was a thief i know how to
tell you yeah what kind of [ __ ] you do
everything every loan what's the
craziest [ __ ] thing you do that won't
get you in too much trouble no i robbed
drug dealers and [ __ ] like that but for
a while i worked hotel rooms
they're very easy now i can't do it
now you can't do it but back in the day
i would just wait i would just wait for
a hoe i would go to a hotel dressed up
in a [ __ ] suit with a wall street
journal
like i was going to meet a friend there
and i'd say what time does the i'd
contact and then when they weren't
looking i'd slip in and go through up to
the third floor
i'm the type of guy in those days that i
would watch and made and there's a lot
of maids would put the keys in the door
and leave the keys in the door and go in
the [ __ ] hotel because i leave on my
[ __ ] in the hotel people yeah that's god
it's got to be a gold mine no no no no
listen in hotels hey room rule number
one i never
nobody goes in my room
you don't need to clean my room though
which is what do not disturb all times
all the time that's not really the turn
for a thief
but why have people eyes
knowing what you have that don't aren't
supposed to know
that's how it's done i worked security
at the crestwood when i was a kid at 19.
and you have no idea and i was i was the
bad one what's the christmas the
craftsman was a hotel in snowmass
village and i was secure there was two
of us from five to one we had to walk
around and drive people to the airport
and pick them up and [ __ ] like that and
there was another guy that was there the
guy that got me the job was a bigger
thief than i was he was scamming it from
two ways he would watch you coming in
he knew you put money in the safe at the
[ __ ] hotel
so he would watch when you went skiing
and he get the key from the no no no no
no no you don't trust nobody
that's how you have to when you go to a
hotel nobody well that's my thing all
the time nobody when we play gigs it's
like
going to be in the hotel or backstage
with the gig nobody both of them are
supposed to no no i don't [ __ ] around
you know we were talking about
what do you do what do you do with it
then hotel safe or not
i take everything with me
just keep it listen i want to steal my
[ __ ] computer from 10 years ago that
i want to throw out a window every two
weeks go ahead take it
there ain't no nude pictures in there
ain't dick in there in fact i got two
gmail accounts with a podcast
and they're different computers my house
podcast
my house computer gets different emails
than the gmail on the road i'll go on
the road like now i haven't been on the
road for three weeks i open up that
[ __ ] computer there's two thousand
emails
it's the weirdest [ __ ] thing so you
could rob what are you gonna rob my
clothes
my ipod is one of those portable ipods i
buy those cheap ones so they fall on
planes with the circle thing yeah the
speakers
you could take those little [ __ ]
earpods so anything important you keep
on using yeah you get this your credit
card
your [ __ ] license and your phone
you keep on you what else do you want to
have on you you got a ring and a chain
you put it on
you go to the gym you take it out and
you put it i try to not take anything
too nice with me on well my thing is too
is it's harder for musicians as
instruments
i've done things wheeler that i can't
believe i got away with
that this this can't really be happening
like when i was out there robin
you can't be this like i was writing a
joke the other day like i'm not i wasn't
really a thief
but if you're to be that stupid i had to
rob you
like if you're going to be that stupid
you're going to run give me an example
i'm fascinated by this i was in the
supermarket once i was [ __ ] flat
broke with my ex-wife it was a friday in
aspen
and we probably have 22 bucks for the
weekend we're buying like coke cuts and
tuna fish and sodas we were staying at a
hotel
on main street across from the in-n-out
sandwich shop this is way not in-n-out
burgers this is [ __ ] not burgers
wasn't even a thought
and i'm in this [ __ ] supermarket and
i see this [ __ ] lady
going through the products reading the
caloric intake and [ __ ] you don't need
to [ __ ] know just grab the [ __ ]
product
with her purse on the place where you
put produce
and i never love sticking out
and i just timed it it's just like a
fighter when you're a thief you just
time
as soon as she goes back the timing and
i just zipped the [ __ ] envelope
popped and walked around the corner with
600 bucks in there no if you're gonna be
that stupid i'm gonna take it i i got
stuck in santa monica tonight
i'm not proud of this
i'm not proud of this at all and this
will answer a lot of questions to the
people in the podcast there was a time
i would walk into [ __ ]
toys r us with my four-year-old daughter
at the time
i'd walk in there with 60 bucks i'd
leave there with a bicycle
and 600 worth of toys
you know what without walking
out
of the [ __ ]
uh
toy store
that was a time when i was in you know
how you know how they have how did you
do that
in those days
fake returns
you know there was a time you know they
did this movie
last year but back out of content with a
fresh helicopter
what's that man straight out of straight
out of compton and it's a great movie i
love it i like backgrounds
and they they talk about it they talk
about him financing
his early career with drug money
my early comedy career 93 94 95 96 i was
a professional shoplifter
if it didn't have [ __ ] screws on it
it i took it
do you think there was a uh
i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] the world
attitude that allowed you to do that oh
yeah there was a there was a certain
anger because what you're saying right
now makes me like want to do it but like
i could see years ago like when i was
like if you don't give a [ __ ] and you're
[ __ ] pissed off no i was angry at the
world i wasn't happy with myself
you know i i had a low [ __ ] esteem in
myself i didn't really give a [ __ ]
i was getting into comedy i'd been
divorced i'd already been to prison i
had nothing to lose anymore i remember
one day i got to pick up my daughter and
it's christmas day
and i got 20 dollars
i got toys for her that was the easy
thing but now i had to get decorations
so i [ __ ] took like christmas
decorations and duct taped
them to the wall and a bunch of [ __ ]
christmas things and i gotta go get a
tree and i'll never forget this i went
to the cayman
and next to the kmart there was a tree
lot
and as i walk up you're not gonna
believe this
there's an envelope and it says pick a
tree and put the money and checks in the
[ __ ] thing i reach my hand in there
two three hundred dollars who knows
that's how i eat dinner that [ __ ] you
know i went back eight months later
and gave the guy the money seriously
yeah
like that's the old school but
at that day that helped me out
why would somebody leave envelopes out
there
and leave you know i didn't take the
checks i just took the cash
we were talking we were pitching today
in uh
in fx
and we were talking about the character
the jew attorney
and i was telling them play by lee
we're trying
and i was telling them a story that i
got a job at the alpine country club i
was fresh out of the bartending school
i worked at the sheridan center and they
gave me a job
they got me the only way you could work
at the shattering center is by being
trained at barton school at the time
it's 1984.
so they paid for your training was 200
bucks for two weeks
you learn how to pull drinks it's
[ __ ] yeah but when you're 18 you
really believe it like i'm gonna bartend
in school make 400 a night you know
whatever
but when i got suspended from
the [ __ ] sheridan i didn't tell the
american barton school part of the deal
is nationwide
placement for the rest of your life
if you go to the american bar if the
american bartender school still exists
if you go there you get nationwide and
they have schools all over the country
so when you move into the area you go to
that school
and they'll give you [ __ ] job
placements if they have it i wonder if i
took one day of bargaining class i
couldn't everybody did everybody wanted
to be a bartender for everybody
everybody saw that movie with tom cruise
and donald trump i was gonna get [ __ ]
[ __ ] but yeah
but i went to i got a job at the i got a
call from the american bartender in
school and they go listen
oh
go down to the alpine country club
they're doing a banquet
you're a banquet bartender you're gonna
make 12.50 an hour now at this time i'm
on the run
i'm hiding low and [ __ ] uh fort lee
new jersey i got people in north bergen
looking for me and i'm still making my
little moves to the city and [ __ ] as
long as i don't go back to north bergen
or around that area
and i'd work this [ __ ] thing
and i see that there's a
they're giving the head bartender
a key
and when people give him gifts he's to
put them
in the back room
and what it was was a bar mitzvah
all right and he went back there maybe a
hundred times with envelopes and [ __ ]
he said to me listen i gotta go upstairs
and cater apart everybody like two hours
he left that key that [ __ ] momo
on top of the register do you know what
my low life 20 year old self did
i wanted that dude that dude sounds like
he was about to have a bad bar mitzvah
dog i opened up every [ __ ] envelope
and i took the cash out of the mlos the
ones that had checks i just left them in
there
and the ones that had cash i just took
them i think i scammed like 1200 bucks
did they have a lot of ones in it
i don't remember i walked
straight out
like i didn't finish the shift that's
how crazy i was like i didn't even care
if they're gonna pin it on me like i
didn't get it
why were you not what was the place you
said you weren't allowed to go to
north bergen why was that i owed money
for coke i owed too many people money
for coke i'd rob a few drug dealers
this is some [ __ ] life this is
craziness but i went and i did this bar
mitzvah i still remember going to harlem
going what the [ __ ]
is going on with my life
and i would go to harlem and buy coke
and weed
and i became tight with the weed dealers
they were all cuban refugees and i go
what do you guys make out here and they
go if we sell
25 bags for five dollars a piece we keep
25 dollars
and i go you have to give him a hundred
dollars i couldn't [ __ ] believe it so
i would always threaten them one day i'm
going to come out here and i'll sell all
these one day i go then the leader goes
come here
i'm short-handed today i got to give you
some weed you have to sell it on the
corner he gives me a bundle 25
nickelbacks i go what do you want me to
stand cause you can stand anywhere you
want but if i was you maybe go to the
top of the corner i went to the top of
the corner and just started running
i just took off the [ __ ] port
authority after i was i was a savage
yeah damn let's see this is the kind of
[ __ ] growing up in kentucky he didn't
think he existed oh no
it was just a matter of time before
somebody [ __ ] shot me when i'm very
lucky
but did it come close to that
absolutely absolutely yeah you had a gun
pointing at you
yeah am i getting too serious no i had a
knife one time in aspen
and i had a guy that came up to me that
had a gun on him that's it the next time
we're in broad daylight
and he goes next time i see you i'm
gonna shoot you that [ __ ] don't happen
too much where i'm from john wolf g jeff
warsaw jay
my man jay from [ __ ] pittsburgh i
can't say your last name because you're
a school teacher
damien gerrard tim norfolk mark allen
mike rix
and my main man always lorne rosenker
i love you [ __ ] also don't
forget celebrity live this weekend
starting thursday night
and 4 20 leveling live oxnard
so your nayak this weekend come by
or if you're a [ __ ] oxnard on 420 or
santa barbara or anywhere in that area
i'll be at the uh levity live
oxnard star one will be there
giving out stars leaving eat like 52 of
them that night dick syat's going to be
visiting from florida
we'll get in the hotel room
it's going to be all over but the
[ __ ] shouting
you know i was telling you guys before
the podcast i don't click on dick
like when people send me all that [ __ ]
online but it goes back to how we were
raised wheeler
i see people that shouldn't be talking a
certain people you ever see that like
go to the hollywood booth yeah i still
can't believe that you don't click on
porn
blow my mind no
because that [ __ ] just jacks your
computer i could jerk off from fantasies
okay i could jerk off through fantasy
yeah no no no no you don't know what
goes on that [ __ ] years ago i clicked
onto something i got 92 [ __ ] things
gay people were sending me notices
i don't even know that [ __ ] okay no just
see ya
so i don't click on the deck i really
don't i don't click on the dick when
people send me stuff redo your banking
or retype your information i just click
it and take my chances
i don't know but it goes back
to how i was raised because i see people
you go to hollywood boulevard yeah and
see [ __ ] up people on there
and you see like a [ __ ] up guy who
stops tourists and he's trying to scam
like why come from you don't even stop
don't challenge him because he's gonna
get you he's either gonna get you or the
guy down the corner is gonna get you
they're gonna weaken you by eight people
approaching you but if you don't stop i
don't stop at all i've never stopped my
mother would not let me stop you don't
you don't learn this [ __ ] where i'm from
i guess no you don't that's why new york
city still freaks me out yeah you don't
stop you keep walking you don't make i
don't know what you're talking about if
they really get in your mug you're from
another country especially deutsche
you just say some two words and they go
oh we're sorry you just keep [ __ ]
walking you know how many times i i've
talked to talent i don't even know what
the [ __ ] i'm saying italian you'll get a
german one time and then you'll be
[ __ ] no i never said germany i never
never speak now no i'm just whatever the
[ __ ] they tell me they speak i don't
speak it at all
you know i don't talk i don't stop to
talk
because that's how they weaken you like
young girls like i'm gonna raise my
daughter you don't have to stop excuse
me
i don't know nothing i don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about if you
don't make the contact nothing can
happen
nothing can happen well what happened i
pulled over to help some guy and he
[ __ ] me in the air well that's what
you get for being a christian you know
what i'm saying
that's what you get out of being a
[ __ ] christian it's harsh man it's
but it's the truth
when you see all these low-level scams
people put on people on the internet
especially i'm not uh what's the word
internet sassy with scams savvy savvy
but i know i wouldn't put my [ __ ]
credit card and birth certificate in
there so you know what i'm saying like
there's little things you know
that you just can't do you know that's
why i like amazon i trust amazon there's
a couple companies you got to trust you
give them the work credit but somebody's
probably [ __ ] gotten ripped off from
amazon but yeah i know my mom did my mom
did someone stole
her amazon uh gift card like they
brought they broke in her account and
ordered stuff and then amazon wouldn't
give her the the credit back
never gave it back to her she refuses to
go to amazon now because they [ __ ] it
yeah
and then that
it's weird with that one because if you
ever have to do a return like you have
to go and ship it and then they don't
have a number you have to go back and
give them your number they call you it's
weird
so there's no perfect system anymore
no i don't uh but it all goes back to
that just don't get involved
you don't know nothing i don't know
nothing i'm sorry well i needed these
lessons when i was a kid they they
talked to you they called you mr wheeler
and said you would write this
i don't know what you're talking about
because people come up to you with
assumptions also
that's the best and i come up to you
with assumptions of things you're gonna
do
what i get all the time now is people
like i don't know how they got my email
or whatever facebook like send me lyrics
and [ __ ] song ideas hoping that
probably that i'll write one close to
that so they can [ __ ] sue me
but i gotta i try to just delete it
really fast no it's really quick how
they have different
when the death squad thing started
getting popular with rogan it's it's it
it it got obscene
how they would work each one of us
like i would i would get on the plane
and often are we go you know this guy
named john smith yeah he keeps emailing
me about a tv show yeah you know and
they want to talk to rogan rogan don't
want to talk to nobody
if you want to talk to rogan you got to
call his manager he don't take a call
an offer he don't know nothing
you send rogan an offer and you just
shot yourself in the [ __ ] leg and i
got to be the same way
because you got to cover yourself
you know we try to be nice people yeah
come out to my birthday party i'll give
you the cash you want and then you get
then you're going to sleep in the barn
with the meal
or you know you gotta go meet the whole
[ __ ] family all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you gotta get that how about 10
grand my birthday sounds good yeah
that's it or not it's a [ __ ]
nightmare lease so when people contact
me now i'll even answer them back
you contact me all you want about your
[ __ ] gigs
go on imdb and see what the [ __ ] you got
to contact and call them that's your
best shot
because i got a wife and a kid you know
i i'm just not going to go to some
[ __ ] town and take my chances i got
to get covered you know the whole from
[ __ ] a to z and i say this
because i've been burnt 30 times
i've been burnt 30 times you know you
say that you learn from experience
what's the worst burn you got you think
like a thousand bucks when i really
[ __ ] needed it
and how this how they get you
um
no ticket sales not enough ticket sales
there's always a [ __ ] story but then
that night i got a knock on my door from
the radio station he ran out in the
radio station too
that was my fault i got a deposit i
always got a deposit and i got half of
my deposit like half my pay when i got
there
you know a lot of clubs say don't send a
check i might chuck barry [ __ ]
i leave with my cash yeah you know
there's no reason to send me a phone i
remember we were leaving a gig and this
guy wanted to uh
um
take his picture with me he's like i'm
the promoter
and i was in the [ __ ] van i was like
i didn't want any [ __ ] like
i had i was there for three hours take a
picture then so just leave
next day my manager calls he's like
there's like 80 [ __ ] people on your
facebook page saying that you were a
[ __ ] last night it was that same
dude who didn't get his picture taken
like black like covered my facebook page
and like [ __ ] insults and [ __ ]
and then uh
i told my people that just like don't
ever book me at this [ __ ] it's just
like it was a way to like make me trying
to make me look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like saying that like
i was being a dick but they were like
claiming that i was being a dick
backstage listen two weeks ago i was
wearing magoobies
in baltimore
the place seats 300 400 [ __ ] people
per show
okay
they have a certain area where you could
mingle you can't go out in between shows
you can't go out in between the first
and second show
because there's 700 people out there and
it's all congested they're trying to
clean out the room
and these people want to take pictures
so last week i didn't take pictures for
the first show
did i feel bad [ __ ] yeah i felt bad
but it's too much controversy people
don't get it people don't want to
[ __ ] do it
people that you know like there's
there'll be a line for people coming out
of the second show
and they'll be taking pictures but then
there'll be a line for people going into
the first show and they'll walk away
from the line
to take pictures instead of wait until
after the show
so that now there's an argument with
them because they didn't [ __ ] walk
away from the line it's always something
so the club will tell the club told me
like a year ago different club said do
us a favor don't go out there in between
shows because it's just too much it's
too much confusion and our weight staff
can't get the tables clean
they can't run with those people in the
hallways
so that's the only time i won't take
pictures is in between shows if they're
busy
and if the place shares the same door
there's a lot of places i could send
people out the back door and take the
pictures from stage but then they're
still in the way of the [ __ ] wait
staff
so it's a no-win situation people are
going to get pissed off you know now
people don't come to the late show come
thursday
now people know don't come early because
the places are small they get packed
well for you you gotta piss off
unfortunately it's better for you to
piss off the fans and the owner you know
no no no i [ __ ] the owner i'd rather the
people who pay to come see me listen to
the podcast and they're gonna come see
you
i love those [ __ ] you gotta
they're family they're not even fans i
don't want no fans that's when i was 13.
these people are [ __ ] family
sometimes i just it's just business
i can't start the show an hour late
because i took pictures do you follow
them say anything oh yeah it's business
it's just straight up business they're
trying to run a business i'm trying you
know i can't start the show an hour and
15 late because both crowds are in the
hallway
the wait staff can't be productive so in
return if i take pictures it's like the
law i'm getting the lower the law of
diminishing returns
it's going to be too much let's just
avoid the pictures the first show we'll
take them the second show if you want go
to a bar and come back i hang out out
there you know for about an hour as long
as i can
so
you can't take it you can't please
everybody is what i'm trying to say
that's the business we're in and in life
you can't please everybody people gonna
get pissed off for you for doing certain
things i couldn't go to a wedding on
saturday
she never comprehended it
since the day she invited me i explained
to her that
it's 13 hours
to come to your wedding
and then i got to stay there
for four days until night i can't do
that
i got a wife and a kid i got to help my
wife out you know i got home today from
traffic at 4 30. i left the house at six
i didn't see the kid i would have loved
to take a nap before i came here
didn't work out that way she wanted to
see me had to go outside and play
[ __ ] soccer with it till 6 30 and we
ate then i came over here
if i don't do that then i won't have a
family
then i'll have a career but i won't have
a family i have nothing at home and then
when the kid's 18 she's not a therapist
saying that i didn't pay attention to it
because i was a comedian do you
understand me totally it doesn't have a
[ __ ] end so before that [ __ ] happens
i pay attention
that's what i need seems like you gotta
kind of all figured out in a lot of ways
when you fail so many times you'll learn
how to figure it out i didn't write this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i didn't write this i'm a 54 year old
losing it learned it to write you know i
got the i got married i bought the
american dream
and you get you go to college you're
like i want to do what
i'm going to do what i'm not doing that
and you change everything and also when
people are unhappy you end up with a
divorce and a kid
and now you gotta run two families
because guess what as soon as you
divorce your wife there's always that
hot chick that wants to come along you
gotta start all over again
so now you got to pay child support you
got this chick here you got to take her
out for dinner on friday she's not going
to suck your dick on an ice cube in the
mouth you know what i'm saying like papa
likes on friday night
it's a [ __ ] nightmare
yeah i mean i i will say i've probably
learned more from failure than all no
you learn from failure you learn from
getting hit in the pocket
you know you learn from getting hit in
the pocket you're following me
when you're uh giving somebody half your
[ __ ] money and you gotta sell your
house and you learn i made a mistake
next time i'm going to play a little
[ __ ] closer to my chest
that's how you learn in life it's not by
reading a book
because you're not going to listen or
read
the art of war is going to teach you how
to
or the war of art is going to teach you
how to plan and strategize or both how
to [ __ ] uh get rid of your fears or
whatever but it's not going to tell you
what to do and what not to do what's a
mistake and what's not a mistake
nobody knows the two do you think kenny
rogers
when he invested in that [ __ ] chicken
company
he thought that no you know they came to
him with a deal
who the [ __ ] knows until you try it
can't you rogers
roasters that chicken was so shitty oh
my god it was horrific didn't kenny
rogers ever go in there one time
but they paid him a lump sum and they
used it
oh dude he probably made a [ __ ] he
played more than a fortune he that's how
he got the face left
that's how he got the whole [ __ ] that
was a lot then he if if that paid for
that he sold a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
no but it's it's it's uh
you don't [ __ ] get smart by [ __ ]
reading a book or
reading about nostradamus you get smart
by [ __ ] family and then you decide
what you're not not gonna do no more
i won't be doing that [ __ ] no more you
know what i'm saying oh totally i mean
i've
that's been my whole [ __ ] career is
one failure after another then
probably same thing that happened to you
is when i said [ __ ] it throw it all
against the wall just let's see what the
[ __ ] happens then it works
nothing happens until you put your balls
in the line
nothing's gonna happen nothing you're
not gonna lift yourself spiritually
you're not gonna lift yourself as a
human being nothing happens until you
take chances well that record was my
money on the [ __ ] oh sure sure it was
my money if it didn't sell if you didn't
sell on i lost the money but even that
it wasn't about the money with you no it
was never about the money with me at all
lee was it about the money when we
started [ __ ] around anything
a hundred bucks a week
not about the money if you're doing this
to get rich
you don't really want to do this
you have to do this because you're
feeling you're nuts and you believe in
yourself and you're like you know what
i'm gonna do this and watch i'm to prove
all you is [ __ ] wrong
and that's exactly what you did which
takes a lot of balls when i heard that
pure [ __ ] anger yeah pure anger you
know and that's mixed and you take a
chance and guess what if that wouldn't
work you didn't [ __ ] cheryl crows
first down get ganked in the radio
stations didn't atlantis morissette
have a [ __ ] album that was a disaster
in canada then she came here
listen you don't learn and then she
fixed all the glitches
she said oh wait a second i'm not a
lounge singer
i'm a [ __ ] pot you know what i'm
saying that's how you like i'm saying
like dylan getting booed off the stage
yeah people booed [ __ ] bob dylan
for going electric yeah when he was just
grown
when he was growing he was inventing
this new form of rock he was inventing
the band basically yeah and growing no
no no it's uh
you
i was watching something then they were
talking about revenge
you know that it's the same result but
uh sometimes you uh lift from even pain
a parent dying a brother dying an animal
sometimes you use pain to get to the
next level
you know there's next levels as a human
being you're never gonna know him unless
you jump in that [ __ ] lord
you never know what you could do unless
you could jump in that water well it's
like that famous dylan show the royal
albert hall show in 66 was a
the famous judas some guy in the crowd
screamed judas
i mean he [ __ ] flipped out
and he goes uh
he screams i don't believe he looks back
at the band the band he goes play it
[ __ ] loud and they played uh like a
rolling stone
most famous concert of all time there's
colin and judas
you can hear it you can go buy the
[ __ ] records you know it's the best
rock i've ever heard and like i said
best band i've ever heard in my life and
they're booing them what's going on lee
how you feeling over that tarzan
not feeling
amazing it didn't do nothing to you
you're bulletproof he feels amazing but
he can't get the word amazing no no let
me tell you something he's this kid is a
[ __ ] jewish tank of death
i could never sink him i'll tap out
before he's he doesn't know if he
doesn't need 2 000 stars he doesn't know
he'll stay at home i will say he looks
pretty good now and then he'll tell me
how he's not getting high on stars no
more and i'll go lee because you ate
four [ __ ] stars and you ate 2 000
milligrams of man on monday night
how are you going to go backwards you
got to go upwards
see i always heard the weed wasn't uh
you couldn't get a tolerance i guess not
yes you can you get the talent for the
stars
after a year you gotta tolerance
anything if you smoke weed every day
that's why i never understood people
about a pound of wheat because after a
week you're not getting as high as you
were the first time and even if you take
that weed and put it away for a while
you'll get high when you re-smoke it but
not as high as you did the [ __ ] first
time i rotate weeds
i got one two i got four weeds right now
i got two here what kind of way did you
let me see the [ __ ] that killed uh
kennedy was we smoked the [ __ ] that made
legal purple
i got this [ __ ]
that my friend grew up in the mountains
and i got a container over there i don't
know what that is i don't even know what
it's been there it's like a general weed
for anybody who wants to smoke
but at the house i got a
something like neptune og and i got it
and i got some other [ __ ] that's what's
neptune og neptune i just left it there
tonight because i had all this [ __ ] i
didn't know if you smoked or not i
usually got four types of wheat i smoke
one in the morning one for lunch and i
trick myself you know what i'm saying
like i'll trick myself
and then i'll save the weed that's the
strongest i'll save like two bowls for
sunday when i get off the plane let's
say i smoke that weed on monday
when i get off the plane on sunday that
weed's gonna be strong again you follow
me no yeah no i don't i never thought
about it you got to play this [ __ ] you
got to play the hand you got to trick
your body lee you know
i know i don't look that great wheeler
but like if like you took this and no
disrespect like you would probably call
the ambulance if you took what i took
tonight yeah
he took one if you would have smelled
chinese man yeah no no and give him five
more minutes he turned into [ __ ]
general ciao
give him five more minutes now he don't
look chinese he'll be general child over
there and [ __ ] like that
talk to me about this new
you press you press the record button um
uh it's uh it's called the new out you
just fart no
it's telling about my new record you're
just [ __ ] ripping farts i would never
do but
the police is coming hit them with the
sound effect doug
oh jesus christ
this is ten minutes can you believe what
i gotta deal with there you go
right on time
all right what is the new album
um it's called old wheeler this is one
of my favorite records
my favorite country records is called
old whalen it was wayland records called
oh william and i was listening to a lot
when i was making the record i'm like
because the first albums you know just
they said a lot about first-rate
directors your whole life up until then
this one is just really my life from the
first record to the the second one
life on the road and really being
feeling like an old man like
these [ __ ] new apps where girls
[ __ ]
texting you their [ __ ] [ __ ] this
new world that we're living in i don't
understand [ __ ] unders in some ways
i'm not like an old man
and i'm just kind of a
man out of time i guess i should say
like
meet these [ __ ] like girls tweet you
their [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] like this
is just this world i don't know so it's
really a record about um
um
an old i guess maybe redneck gets old is
really the the word describe it just
a man
you know some southern man at a time
playing new york city and meeting girls
and just
being lost really was is what the
what kind of uh
influenced the record and uh
i'm right a lot i'm so i'm so happy with
it i think it's way better than the
first one all right so where do you sell
this album itunes
yeah what day what day is this coming
out tomorrow no june 2nd i don't know
what this comes out on wednesday the
20th uh the 31st you can start
pre-ordering it on itunes okay
um
and also i got i decided to here let me
do a sales pitch number 11.
i was like [ __ ]
i'm keep cause i own it i'm like i'm
gonna keep the price down you pre-order
it 6.99 because to me the digital
feedback tremendous that's tremendous
because i'm like a digital file it's not
a right because i grew up with like you
with records right like if you're gonna
buy a digital file it's just a [ __ ]
file like like insurance but i'm saying
it's like it's like yeah
like when you buy a there because
whatever the digital companies are like
we own it for life i was like yeah when
i bought microsoft word i own it for
life i could never [ __ ] find it if
you asked me
to find my own computer old software
programs for 10 years ago i don't have
that [ __ ] so i just keep the digital
copies
low priced and just
hopefully i'll sell more that way but um
uh
i don't mean to spend all my time
talking about pricing but
yeah um
starting this friday you can start
pre-ordering it and now you're gonna
tour this out how hot yeah which cities
are you going well we're doing a week of
record release shows second the second
nashville
sixth in new york eighth here hopefully
you guys can make it out
and then after that we're gonna take a
little probably a couple weeks off and
figure out what
kind of torment we're going to do
are you going to release it on pornhub
again
um
yeah we tomorrow morning i got to get up
[ __ ] early
because i'm doing a shooting a video in
the morning and then
there's i'm not making this [ __ ] up
there's [ __ ] naked titties in the
video
we're gonna premiere the video this
ain't no regular pop country [ __ ] we're
preparing the [ __ ] video with naked
tits on pornhub
see that's ingenuity that's american
ingenuity ain't [ __ ] around anymore
so i ain't garth brooks [ __ ] i had never
heard of what you were talking was i
what you were talking about with rogan
they used to release albums for free
before they came out
i can stream them
well yeah i know a lot of the albums
these days like
places like npr and that [ __ ] like
get a taste of it there and i i tried
all these places like here's my album
you can play it for free and they
wouldn't even take it so i i was like
who would play my album for free a week
before to let people have a taste
so we contacted pornhub they're like we
love it yeah
and those guys have been great to me
they gave me free [ __ ] ads
like i said what if i sold my album to
like
even one percent of the world's
[ __ ] i'd be the richest man in
the world
it's like go where the audience is
they're all [ __ ] whacking off listen
man that's what they did with sons of
anarchy the dvds they told them harley
david's in stores oh it's brilliant how
they made their biggest [ __ ] yeah
they sold all the dvds at
harley-davidson stores
they were partners with harley davidson
or some [ __ ] and that's how you do it
it's american [ __ ] ingenuity yeah
that's what you did man and i go i go
where's i go what's the most popular
website i go to
you go to my computer you press p
[ __ ] pornhub comes right up
it's the hub of porn that's the hub you
love it hundley you love porn that's
what my computer does too yeah yeah see
we're we're [ __ ] from this i
want them between pornhub and youtube
newport
um it might be the same company yeah
it's probably all the same [ __ ] let's
tell you what let me see both [ __ ]
are great see i actually go to porn md
because it searches all the other sites
see yeah one md i don't know that yeah
it searches all this that's where it
figures out like what your ailment is
for too much porn yeah but uh so you go
to pawn md and what do you type in and
you can type in whatever you want but
that this is so this is what pornhub
owns when you type in what do you want
to see
what i want to see uh joey diaz no what
do you want to see i don't know probably
yeah usually chubby girls
i like chubby i like uh i like blow jobs
hold on what else what's it called
big what's the big what's it called bbw
bb oh yeah big beautiful woman yep
all those so pornhub owns
uh red tube upon tube eight yeah well
i'll tell you what they've been [ __ ]
great to me because i'm the only one and
the only [ __ ] artist out there
playing music who will talk to them you
know yeah i mean it's all
you know
why ignore that audience in the bible
they also did like a comedy contest
viewpoint didn't they probably i don't
know they're doing a comedy contest and
listen man
whatever works the reason why you're
sitting in that chair is i like what you
do and i like the balls that you did
so that's the only reason i love it i
love the music
i love your attitude i love that you
told them all to suck your dick
you know what you what's really fun is
playing a club in like the south and a
bunch of whole audience of dudes with
the backwards baseball caps just
screaming which one are you queer is
going to suck my dick along with me
tremendous sit on my face
which one of you queen is going to suck
my dick this is
[ __ ] tremendous you can't even a
record label would see that and [ __ ]
themselves and run like hell so i don't
want you around i want somebody like oh
you know what we're going to [ __ ] put
this we're going to run this somewhere
now this serious player music yeah
outlaw country's been pretty good to me
i mean they get a lot of blow back you
know but they got the balls to keep
playing which was cool they uh
they've been
a couple i mean a couple of the stations
play i think it's the outlaw country
station that plays it which is
good because they call themselves outlaw
country so that's cool i'm trying to
think who else plays it
i think stern played a couple times
maybe i don't know did you do stern
awesome i did the after show when i was
in new york all right what's that the
minor leagues to get on the stream i
have no idea i don't know how it works
anymore i don't listen to dick
i'm too busy trying to [ __ ] keep
above water yo i'll tell you what i
don't want to do is the [ __ ] radio no
there's nothing to listen to yeah i
listened to sirius in the car i listened
to ozzie's bone yard oh that's good yeah
i listened to
uh the one that played sound garden
rooster and all that [ __ ] oh yeah the
other day i was listening you guys were
listening i [ __ ] love allison's
channel you listen to a man in the box
man the box i listen to studio 54
sometimes in the daytime i'll put that
on i have a question for you now
speaking of that do you think disco gets
a bad rap
everyone seems to hate i think it's some
of that shit's [ __ ] killer awesome
man people are gonna hate everything
that's different
or popular when disco came along this
ghost you know
[ __ ] it up for a while i remember them
burning disco albums and [ __ ] they had
the big thing in the white sox stadium
or whatever yeah i remember all that was
it disco they were burning or somebody's
rap
so let's bring rock and roll back but i
listened to that [ __ ] now it's like it's
some of that shit's so good that
boogie yogi and yeah this is a couple
grand jams that get you going classic
this you can't listen to um
you know
what's the big uh
bg's hit um stay in the line stan you
can't listen to staying alive and say
that sucks no you can't you can't listen
you can't listen to the whole side of
that live album can i favor you and say
it sucks you can't just kill himself it
was that night on sunday fever i'm sorry
you can't it's a great [ __ ] album and
when you if you don't listen to it every
day and you put it on like somebody like
me that heard it every day for a year
and then stopped like i didn't listen to
that [ __ ] ever again but now sometimes i
hear that one jam from it i can we touch
in the morning rain that one whatever
the bee gees oh yeah that's a great too
that one that's the ballad the one that
they were dancing to how deep is your
love yeah how deep is your love they got
the other one uh alakazam yeah staying
alive with someone
when they're dancing all [ __ ] up at
that club you know you know andrew dice
claire used to do
travolta impersonations at that club
like when he was a kid cyanide fever was
big and andrew would go to that club
whatever the [ __ ] it was called
and dance like travolta and they'd pay
him no that's a good game [ __ ]
tremendous
but uh lee how you doing if you're
looking you're starting to look around
yeah it's over philly that's it he's
trying to tell me he's in training and
[ __ ] on the week i did 13.50 i did
sixteen hundred and i went to the ice
house
and nothing happened i'm high but yeah
yeah no i gotta vouch for this dude he's
pretty [ __ ] up nice he's good yeah
yeah he's good he's solid tonight like
the rock of [ __ ] japan i gotta i'll
tell you what that transmission fluids
hit you later see i got a piss all right
go this way i'll write this out and uh
go through here right through here
okay
look at me all [ __ ] up
first of all listen to me and listen to
me quickly people
i i love lee i don't know i listen to
him when he tells me you know he had a
problem one night with uber they sent
some [ __ ] dude over here
and then he got lyft so one night he
turned me on at the [ __ ] lift
and you know what man like i told you
the cars are clean i like that light in
the front to tell you that they're there
what do you like about lyft i think the
drivers are more friendly i think the
drivers are uh
they tend to be nicer and uh it tends to
be
just an overall better experience well
listen lyft is right-sharing company
that believes in treating its people
better lyft believes that being a
ride-sharing driver should be fun if
you're having a good time so are your
passengers
only liftoff is an in-app tipping when
you drive for lyft you keep 100 of your
tips
drivers have been paying over 150
million in tips since the feature was
introduced
express pay
lets drivers get paid almost instantly
instead of waiting for weeks
lyf has even taken the guesswork out of
pickups the new amp device uses color
coding to help passengers find their
drivers
you can earn hundreds of dollars a week
plus tips
and if you want to make more money drive
more it's never been easier to give
yourself a raise it's a simple formula
happy drivers mean happy passengers
maybe that's why nine out of ten lift
rides get a perfect five-star rating so
join the ride-sharing company that
believes
in treating its people better you're
looking for a job guys you're in between
jobs
you [ __ ] want to put on an album
you're singing songs you don't know here
there's a thousand things you could do
and pick up
listen the one left guy i talk to he
does hardwood floors
and on the weekends and a couple nights
a week he [ __ ] drives to support his
family you have no more excuses to sit
on the couch okay lyft has a job for you
you got a car you got insurance
it's a beautiful car what are you doing
with it you're sitting at home go to
lyft go to lyft.com joey today and get a
500 new driver bonus that's lyft.com
joey lyft.com
joey if you're gonna drive make some
money this is the way to make extra
money in your spare time and make as
much money as you wanna make and it's
all up to you you run your own little
lift service there so go to lymph.com
joey today and get a 500 new driver
bonus that's lyft.com joey today limited
time only terms apply
guess what [ __ ]
beat season is coming
okay you're going to the beach you don't
want to get sand stuck in your ass and
stuff in your little monkey guys you
never want to get sand stuck in your nut
sack you'll never get that stuck out
that stuff out guess what
but days are here to help you out for
the summer all right you don't have to
walk around with rotten ass no more you
know what rotten ass does to you it
gives you hemorrhoids
it gives you infections your pubic hands
fall out of the [ __ ] you don't need
this aggravation in your life
so go do me a favor
go to
hellosquishy.com right now and take a
look at the portable bidets they have
delivered right the ass with a 60-day
guarantee you understand me they don't
[ __ ] around you got 60 days you don't
like it if it breaks you send it back 60
day guarantee i got one in my house lee
tell them has your [ __ ] changed since
you've been using them a day there
hasn't been a day since i installed this
installed it that i don't think
think that i have it and that i don't
use it i use it every single day
she does she likes it too i like it more
though i'm telling you men and women
this is your chance right here to watch
that [ __ ] monkey wash that [ __ ]
and keep it refreshed all day go to
hellotushy.com right now
and slash church and get 10 off your
order all right
spray your butt clean with tremendous
fresh water and what you do is you don't
[ __ ] use tap water if you don't want
to you got to test the ph because if
you're washing your ass with dirty ph
what's the [ __ ] use go to
hellotushy.com right now slash church
and get 10 off your order but days are
back father's day is coming
mother's day is coming that grandparents
their [ __ ] stinks they're in the
dodge all day get them a bidet for
mother's day and father's day and make
their [ __ ] holiday complete go to
hellotushy.com right now slash church
and get 10 percent off i want to thank
hello tushy i want to thank lyft and i
also want to thank honor.com go to
honor.com and press in church and get 10
off any supplement in the house and
these things
listen money back guarantee on alpha
brain nobody else does that in the
industry okay you got new mood you got
shroom tech sport which i'll tell you
what i take a half a capsule and my
[ __ ] heart's beating i'm breathing
better everything's beautiful all right
one more time honor.com and press in
church boom and get 10 off your order
i'll see you [ __ ] next week don't
forget i'll see you tomorrow night
thursday night
at levity live in uh
nyack new york the former house of the
cuckoo's nest i used to go up there and
get [ __ ] served i love you guys have
a great weekend we'll see you guys next
monday night stay black we never decide
what the clothes on the what
we need we never decide what to close on
snow blind by the [ __ ] uh black
whatever society
black label society there you go well
can i thank you guys for having me am i
interrupting [ __ ] yeah yeah dude i had a
blast i love you guys this is [ __ ]
great
get that mule man
[Music]
you